roll it all right sure I got nothing in
my nose
here hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
and uh I got a special guest that was
[__] up the microphone right out of
the gate uh the one and only the bad boy
from Trenton New
Jersey you know how much [__] I've
gotten from that I know I know the one
and only Paul ver
oh thank you for having me bud I know I
always amazed me how much you don't like
New Jersey and it's literally like it's
like right I still don't understand why
Yankees fans don't like Mets fans it's
like you're all New Yorkers like what is
the problem it's it's not that I don't
like New Jersey it's it's just a
nightmare going through there so the
cursing that I would do it goes a little
further than that just a little uh no
but uh the Met Yankee thing is because
of the fans you know meth fans resent us
and hate us you know they hate us and
all they want to do is why do you guys
always do that what just new Yankees and
giant fans he always thinks everybody's
walking around Thinking About You Met
fans hate us dude nobody cares about you
met fans hate us I got Met fan friends I
[__] go I still have giant fans come
up to me go I'm a giant fan sorry it's
like dude we won we've won three Super
Bowls since then we got over we won six
with that quarterback
yeah I'll take the two losses they do it
every time he all like you're sitting
there going like I'll tell you you know
you know the team that is still [__]
because this is the deal if if we lost
those two and then didn't win three that
would still bug us but you get the three
it goes away right it's like 04 with the
Yankees the [__] anyone an 09 who
gives a [__] right
so the ones who are still hanging on to
it Paul dude I'll say this man Seattle
yeah oh yeah did you see what's his face
uh the uh what's his face the corner
there you mad bro he's on TV now oh uh
uh Rich Richard Sherman he's got that
run the ball he's he's still not over
that yeah oh yeah well you know I know
could c a ring I mean listen and I'll
tell you I've been
there I've been there as a fan I've been
there I've been there dude I remember
being in a warehouse 3 years after Bill
Buckner 3 years after Bill Buckner and I
don't know I was unloading the truck and
I'm like the [__] was he doing in the
game
uh to yourself like alone just out of
nowhere oh yeah it was almost like it
was so [__] up it took like 3 years to
process it yeah and then that that's the
thing it's the tragedy and then what it
it's like uh you got to like you got to
win another championship for that to go
away and then once you win another
championship you can laugh cuz now I I
you know I watch uh I think I said this
recently I feel like I'm [__]
Groundhog Day I said that on on some
podcast I can watch
like the 86 game six collapse and I'm
just just like I can actually now
appreciate like you can watch it I'm I'm
laughing and then I'm also like going
like I mean dude they literally hit like
17 singles in a
row wasn't one extra Bas it single to
right single left weird to bloops right
like yeah they just they just era yeah
um I don't know it was like four singles
a pass ball what was the mooki Wilson
was the mooki Wilson like a swinging
bunt was it mooki who hit I always
forget it was like there's a bounding
ball behind the bag yeah and the Met's
winning I think mooki Wilson did like a
swinging bunt yeah he swung and then he
was like
running we had we had Bill Buckner who's
the only thing worse than his legs was
his glove he had this old ass [__]
his lucky glove rest his soul did he
pass away yes he did rest his
soul rest his
soul rest rest his soul well you guys
did the ultimate man like you guys did
the UL it's the
most I hate to say this about against
the Yankees as I wearing in a Yankee cap
it's the most gangster way to beat I've
never what you guys did in '
04 was it ripped our heart it was I mean
talk about yeah I mean it was 20 who
gives a [__] yeah but it was brutal dude
and it ended a rivalry it ended a rival
it's just like it's over after that it's
over yeah it's like finally getting who
whoever you got a fight just [__] you
know yeah no it killed the whole thing
1918 went away the curse went away I
remember no five yeah it's bad like no
yeah and then I was just like all right
you got 26 27 we're not going to catch
you so yeah oh I really you guys really
get me going I I can't you know no who
gives a [__] I don't um so Paul you're
out here on the uh on the west coast I
am and by the way you said something
every time I by the way every time I
talk to Bill this is a conversation I
have with Bill when I talk to Bill okay
but yeah man what's going on a dude yeah
you come out here we're going to play
golf oh yeah man how's everything the
dude football how are the kids
everything's mother there [__]
drivers out here I swear to God and I
got to tell you dude I felt it today I
actually go I it a woman just came out
two lanes went in front of me it was the
most Reckless thing I've ever seen on a
four there either it was it's either pot
cookie energy or just psycho psycho
driving on the highway and then when
they get on Surface roads like my thing
is they when they go to change a lane to
make a turn like the last third of their
car is still in your lane they can't
like they have no [__] concept of
I've never seen a state like that
everybody they just go like that and
then you beep at them and then they give
you the finger it's like buddy you're
you're in both [__] Lanes don't get
me going with this you getting me going
I don't want to do this Paul she went
right across and I thought of you I
thought of you I go he's right dude cuz
I how bad could it be dude it was like I
could have been killed and the lady was
just like did that like sorry i' I've
tried all games too I've tried
everything oh bless him there he is I
try to like think I try to like like
compliment
him
hey why wouldn't you the is my friend
Sean Quinn put clapped out yeah there he
he is you Fu great job you [__] piece
of [__] he's Philly right he's Philly
great job clapping
loud that's and what was funny too was
the cars were like a dead stop so the
guy's just looking right at him he's he
was up in a truck he there you go there
you go you [__] piece of [__] and
then he ends and then they're both still
like right
there it laad laad told me that one oh
yeah yeah he just uh I've been in the
car with him there you because he had a
temper oh was great there you go there
you go good for you [__] piece of [__]
[__] yeah no but other than that it's a
uh it's a good time dude I went on stage
for like the first time since uh I was
in Greece uh at the store last night
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah man I'm out I'm
going doing some stuff going to San
Diego doing some pods out here man
playing a little golf my if my back my
back permits dude that was a [__] 16
dayer and the other and I bent down and
I felt a little tweak and I go don't do
it again and I laid down and it was like
a little better I just got to watch I
got to stretch um you know dude oh I I I
threw out my back yesterday bringing my
son up the
stairs I was bringing the Sun up the
stairs and I went to hand it to my wife
just when I got it there I was a little
bent over like that the whole back went
out that was it and then I was just
laying down in the yard I was laying in
the yard for like [__] half hour and
then uh I I worked it out pretty good
but then I went to bed and it was a
little [__] up this morning definitely
had to lean on the wall when I was
taking the morning piss but then uh I
got it going again I piss like that I'm
a I'm a one hand on the I'm fighting
that dude I'm a one hand on the W you
can't St why dude why that is the
beginning to being the guy who can't get
up out of the chair and has the blankets
over his
legs oh okay you become that guy I know
what you mean yeah I didn't even think
of that Paul when was the last time you
did like a deep squat like ass touching
your [__] heels and then went back up
you got to do those you just was like uh
I don't know no when I was eight
pretending to be a frog yeah you got to
be able to do that dude oh man you got
you don't got to do just I I literally
if you just do it once a day all these
[__] idiots with like chains around
him at the gym and all that I'm as an
old guy I'm looking at I'm going like
you got you're gonna blow your joints
out yeah you can do that now but right
now what you don't realize what you're
doing is you are getting rid of all the
cartilage you're going to be bone on
bone but these kids today and by the
time they get to be my age they'll
probably be able to [__] we still
have a deal we have a deal from when
you're 70 we have a 200 we have a $200
be 10 pull-ups guess pull when what I
did the Kobe [__] spinorama with the
shoulders what's that whatever they take
your blood out they send it to a vampire
in Eastern Europe [__] you wanted SP
off on it they spin it
ring out a quest France and uh yeah dude
I'm doing I'm doing pull-ups and and uh
chinups dude by 70 you're going to
lose I don't give a [__] if I have to do
HGH I'm going to win that dude that's
$200 I want to give you cuz if you do
that for a 20-y year bet that would be
epic man dude just the humor of seeing a
7-year-old guy on a chin up
bar dude I'm I'll be a playground
everyone playround be oh oh going be all
nervous for me you get to Seven come on
Billy you got three more I want to give
you the money I want to give you the
money um yeah dud I'm getting to the age
it's like you know I see a rookie in a
league it's like am I going to see his
whole
career like if he plays as long as
LeBron how [__] old am I going to be
I knew that I was getting old when I
realized like NBA players now that are
leaving were like yeah it's like dude
LeBron's going to be and LeBron went in
young LeBron's going to be done in two
years LeBron went in when he was 18 Aon
Rogers is going to be he's going to come
back for a year after this injury then
be done they're all gone man everybody's
gone Jeter went to Oldtimer day and
Jeter goes they go what do you think he
goes can we change the name of this
thing he goes I think we need rebranding
because he didn't like the like the
oldtimers you know cuz he looked great
he walked I mean Jeter walked out
looking great but he was like Old-Timers
Derek Jeter when did he leave all of the
990 don't even tell me he left like 2013
he didn't leave that long ago did he
yeah he left I think his last year was
like 12 or 13
wow that only feels like five years ago
oh my godon is there a way to find that
out is he's not 50 is he no no he's like
47 48 well he came into League like
around 2122 at 96 so he was born like 75
retired like 37 38 dude 49 he's 49 what
year did he so he retired what year [__]
2014 wow I took Lucas as a baby and he
couldn't he was too young he's like I
want ice cream and cheater stole a base
and I go he stole a he didn't care yeah
you know he didn't care I'm going to uh
take one of my kids to the maybe know
Bruins Bruins uh Kings game earlier
early in the season I think they come
out I have no idea Paul I [__] just
got over uh I got Co for the second time
how was it the second time around easier
the same as the first I just felt like I
had a cold for two days I never got all
that crazy [__] that like the fatty lost
I lost a smell and taste but I was fine
I wasn't sick I just lost smell and
taste which was weird and I mean like
you lost two of your five senses yeah
but felt great how weird is that I it
was [__] weird dude how do you feel
great not being able to smell or taste
anything goes this Wine's delicious and
I go it [__] stinks and she goes what
she goes Paul such good wine I go it's
[__] horrible and then like then I
started panicking cuz I was like oh my
God smelling whiskey nothing the
strongest whiskey nothing candles is
nothing then I put a Dorito in my mouth
cuz you know the way they got the cheat
and it tasted like I was eating
cardboard it was just oh wow and I was
like oh yeah I got it there was a rock
star that lost his taste sense of taste
he just he got hit in the head or
something like that some people and then
he he like lost it he's dead now he
[__] completely like couldn't handle
it he was doing that [__] you know
you tie a belt around your neck and
start jerking off I mean dude that's got
to be incredible dude for you to take
that risk dude that's got to be [__]
dude
dude that's got to be I mean I would
never do it but could that's got to be
[__] up there dude for dudes to
[__] go a [__] hang themselves
while jerking off D knowing the danger
what's his name was it David who's the
guy David how do you do that like I
don't understand like how do you
actually George Carin talked about that
in his special you basically like as
you're like you're supposed to time it
where like when you're about to [__]
blow your [__] almost lose oxygen and
they said it's just like the [__]
sickest orgasm ever
I I never wanted to combine feeling like
I was getting murdered as I was [__]
room service comes like I'm sorry sweti
[__] eyes are tear get a big red mark
around your
neck no you know what you do is you just
come to the the oh can you come back
later his eyes
are how are you you know funny this is
the uh that's for you this is right
after right after you almost kill
yourself you got a load on your stomach
and then your wife
calls you pick up the phone hello that's
hilarious how's it going yeah I got to
get home man I just been out here too
long what's wrong yeah nothing don't say
nothing what is it h you know that belt
you got me for
Christmas it broke I just had it around
my neck you trying to kill your your no
I was trying my head jerking off are you
alone no you don't touch it and he
starts going at her I wouldn't be almost
killing myself in every hotel room on
the road if you did your [__] job
sweetheart look I don't do drugs I don't
[__] around and I've been eating salads
can I just have this can I just [__]
choke myself while jerking off [__] dude
that's got to be so [__] hard to when
your kids ask them what happened to Dad
o all right leaving how do you do it how
do you do it what are you gonna
say I died from autoerotic
affixation you're my kid's Uncle how do
you tell them oh dude that's tough oh my
God hey guys uh hey Uncle Paul yeah
where's what's the matter you have a
funny look on your
face so did your uncle no so did your
dad oh so did your dad um yeah dude I
don't know be like you know kids
sometimes people get into things that
are
dangerous and are you talking about my
dad dude what would they do with that
did somebody do something to
him no no no nobody it was an accident
it was a terrible accident well mom
never told me
so boy oh boy it's sure like it if you'd
level with
[Music]
me I would know what to do I would just
call the wife and go I can't got truck I
can't I can't what are they do in the
church at the funeral Charles was a good
man he everyone would just be like they
bury in the soup but they still have the
belt around your
neck it's you dead with your [__]
face sitting in the [__] box it looks
so relaxed yeah
he died doing what he
loved choking himself
out what I want to know medically is why
wait so do you does does the UFC start
turning you on like
submissions he's jerking off to him
listen I'm not gay but I would just love
it if a guy would just take my back
while I'm jerking off it choke me out I
mean that's not gay I'm not touching him
whacking off to a UFC fight that's why
no no a UFC fighter is into autoerotic
fixation when some guy takes his back
rather than trying to get out of and he
starts [__] rubbing one out is he
tapping no he's jerking
off genius way to get out of the
hold Conor McGregor immediately let go
of that rear naked Choice what's the
what's the choke called when they when
they oh Guillotine he got him in Guillo
then he started jerking off
everything oh jeez this a Psy game right
when the bell rings you start running at
them [__] jerking
off like all all your [__] muscle
memory is just gone and in that moment
you do the flying
knee and then they would immediately
make it illegal and then and it would be
it would be [__] dud would be named
after you Paul Paul ver rule what's the
Paul ver rule you can't run out a guy
jerking off to begin it to to [__] with
his head wait he did that
yeah it's like the Sha Avery oh [__] sha
Avery rule but it's it's with your dick
dude if I saw a guy jerking off in a UFC
fight against me I'd be like dude you
win touch your
dick I'd be I'd be right up and over the
fence oh [__] dude I used to do a bit
about that a long time ago I was talking
about how men aren't sexy I said a naked
man is either funny or scary depending
on the situation right yeah like if
you're at a baseball game and some guy
jumps out of the stands and a naked guy
runs across the field it's you [__]
dying It's the funniest thing ever but
if you're working home alone late at
night and a naked guy jumps out like a
with his [__] dick and balls and out
you're
like it's like the scariest thing yeah
uh when David tell did that show what is
the show he did on comed Central
Insomniac yes where he would go to he
would perform there but then he would go
to places I love that he went to one
where
like people were into feet and they
would get their feet oiled and like like
guys were into guy feet and it was just
one of those things dude this guy was
just like oiling this guy's foot and it
was just like
oh gross I was just like gross I was
just like that's all gross I got be
honest with you I am not into like uh
you know what really grosses me out is
[__] food and sex when they combine
that [__] do you remember like nine and
a half weeks there was one scene where
he was in the kitchen and all these
condiments and dumping strawberries and
[__] on him just was just [__] nasty
it makes me remember it makes me
remember the Wayne's Brothers movie like
spoofing it where they just started like
like lighting butter on fire they just
started grabbing o they started dumping
bowls of [__] yeah I always feel I don't
I feel like no one had ever done that
and I think there became like these
things and you saw them enough in movies
where you thought people actually did it
like nobody ever took a chick right at
her place and just [__] cleared off a
table breaking [__] and put her on and
she didn't get mad like what the [__]
are you doing you're breaking home my
you ever remember that that was like the
move in the'80s you grab some chick she
stradle you pots flying oh yeah yeah
very rapy yeah who's going to clean this
very rapy it was very grab and [__] it's
a trump error I I remember when I had
friends in high school go dude she blew
me with an ice cube in her mouth and I
was like was it awful was terrible I had
a woman do that like what the [__] are
you do the whole point of a [__] is
to not have cold like what like what
else you going to do that was the
original ice
bath that's where that idea came from
you don't see people [__] in a snowstorm
like get in the yeah I don't get it oh
my god dude that [__] ice bath you
watch how quick that fad comes and goes
it is another that's another the things
like that are killing the planet is when
[__] like that I understand the ice bath
for a UFC fighter for a [__] Olympian
for a professional athlete but just the
average Joe you know you just you know
just [__] take a cold shower it's not
fun to see people go 40 more seconds 40
it's like dude the two things that you
do is you exercise and they say the
thing that's good for um not having a
stroke not having a heart attack belt
around your neck that and uh sauna a
sauna is they say a sauna takes away
like 60% chance of a lot of horrible
things happening to you ice bath I don't
know any proof of anything except that
it looks really all you know about an
ice bath is it sucks for 40 seconds and
then as long as you don't move it's not
that big a deal cuz I saw one one this
kid was already in it and then the other
guy's freaking out and then he's staring
like he's like he's a [__] man and
it's just like what's the point of an
ice bath I think for like inflammation
they also it brings your body
temperature up it's good for this it's
good for immunity yeah it's good for
people who sell ice baths yeah you wake
up you start your day that's what Tony
Robbins said you jump I jump in it I
start my Tony Robins with his voice he
goes ah that's how you start your day
what does that guy do other than telling
people what to do he doesn't do anything
so I don't understand like he's
successful at telling people what to do
dude he's figured out a way to motivate
and like you that me and Rachel make fun
of those people all the time on
Instagram where they have like that
really serious music and they just like
start the day like you know first thing
I do when I start the day is I avoid
water as long as I can and they just say
we say something [__] up like that and
you're just like what and then there's
always somebody going like really oh my
God that's amazing all you have to who
are you yeah yeah why like listen here
here here's a good thing for you kids
out there if somebody has to score their
opinion like a movie yeah yeah yeah
you're probably it's probably [__]
it's always somber with like a little
bit of like this is imag of a car
salesman came out and [__] started
telling you about some piece of [__] car
but they had this intense music let me
tell you something about this old's cut
lless and you're like like yeah dude I'm
not buying that your wife's like dude
how the [__] could you buy that and you
be I don't know man the [__] music
was banging dude the
guy you know how I like Buick I I got I
got caught up oh I love a Buick yeah
back in the day the old school oh dude
I'm an old school dude with that [__]
when I was 16 my stepfather would be
like really you want that like I would
be like can we look at like I would look
at like Buick Las saers yeah you skipped
the whole young fast stupid and you just
went right to bathrob I slippers yeah
cigars I remember my my stepfather's
like what uh I go dude can we get this
Malibu and he goes like really that's
the car I go yeah it's reasonably priced
it's four doors I like the interior he
was just like what who aree you a
[__] 70y old this's one thing I got
to tell like I like the what I've
learned about how to live life I've
learned so much of it from you
oh likewise just G to let you sit with
that pull let you get choked up like
you're choking yourself jerking off um
no as far as like like I used to dude
you know I was [__] scatterbrained
for a long time and now my house like I
go to my house and I just go right to
the back porch and I just [__] sit
out there yeah I and that's every day I
sit out there you can do it alone right
be alone oh yeah or I can or my kids
come out U I'm basically avoiding the
family no um I go out there I have like
a cup of coffee or have like a cigar oh
you know yeah occasionally I'll get the
paper it's the greatest thing oh my god
dude now the paper's the greatest dude
you give me and nice tea you know I like
the paper it's my
voice when I'm reading it I'm hearing my
voice I'm not trying to freak myself out
when I watch the news on TV it it's just
like like I feel like they should just
have like a flashlight under their chin
like the way they're just like scaring
the [__] out of you yeah today in San
Bernardino yeah
wildfires wildfires Paul there's nothing
you can do about
it I can just read about it hey the
[__] cie Valley my dumb voice you
know what it is Bill I really think and
listen Paul what is I'm no I'm no brain
surgeon but I'll tell you what this is
the dumbest time that I remember the
things that are being said the things
that are people doing like it's a big
story that Taylor Swift is in daon
Travis Kelce and she's in the box with
his family it's like that's that's the
story like they even said it during the
game they go and another big thing TMZ
will love Taylor Swift is here that was
part of the announcers in the booth that
was yeah but I can see that I mean
imagine if they get married like that
giant guitarist they're going to make
okay you know a 6 foot6 guy make a
guitar look like a ukulele I could give
a [__] dude I got I mean they're laying
six dude I got to win I don't give a
[__] about Taylor Swift okay I'm trying
to [__] I'm trying to well that has
less to do with it being dumb as far as
like they just doing this thing where
they can't make enough money so they're
just trying to uh it's like what makes
the what makes the Super Bowl suck Paul
is it's the most important football game
of the year and it's treated like the
the football game is the last thing on
anybody's mind when The Rock came out at
Sofi and he was like everybody this is
good I was like dude F it's it's over
it's like the rock you know what that
was for that was for all cuz so many
nonf football fans show up I get it so
they got to do that it was also superl
it was also Hollywoods you got have a
big movie star come out there yeah it
was it's beyond stupid what's what you
have to do is uh you just you tape the
game I always say this you tape the game
you let it get to halftime and then you
have your phones off then you start the
game and you just fast forward through
all of that [__] it's [__] horrible
Paul they used to play the thing in the
afternoon and Kurt gouty would announce
it and it was a [__] football game
they played like a college football
stadium and it could be [__] cold out
or whatever raining out and they just
played the [__] thing yeah [__]
ice bowl Ice Bowl was the NF NF uh the
NFL championship game and they played it
in
Lambo
yeah on the Frozen T they would never do
that now oh it's going to be cold out
and what about
all roof is uh I got a running joke with
my lovely wife right she's cracking up
she all of a sudden cuz we're going to
the Super Bowl this year so all of a
sudden my wife wants to go she like
wants to go I go yeah you're not going
she goes what do you mean I go yeah
you're not going to that she goes no I
want to go I go no you don't I go you
don't give a [__] about football I'm
going to sit on this couch for 18
[__] weeks in a row and I'm going to
watch it and then I'm going to watch
another three weeks of playoffs and
you're not going to be here cuz you
don't give a [__] about I'm not you're
not taking up a seat wow from somebody
and she's going get it she goes you know
us just playing the halftime go see him
when he plays the
Paris you're not no it's not happened so
I just I was like being totally honest
but like so over the top that she was
cracking up and today she was getting
ready she goes oh yeah you know I can't
wait to go to the Super Bowl I said well
you're going to be waiting a long time
I'm like it's a guy's weekend I'm going
golfing with verie she goes I'll leave
you alone I'll leave you alone I'll go
with somebody else I'm like I'm like
no she just wants to see I'm like just
you being there is going to ruin it I'm
like yeah there's going to be hookers
all over the
place there's going to be hookers and
Coke dude hookers and Coke guys are
going to be jerking off the [__] like
how do you fit into that belts around
their
necks I want to come home feeling
guilty Stacy's like PA why you bringing
so many belts to the
Superman for too funny if that was your
thing and you would just open open about
it and like nobody gave a [__] like dude
I can't wait for Vegas I got a brand new
Jordan I got three new belts look how
thick look how thick this is look how
thick this is you know if I hold my head
like this if I hold my head like this
this was literally this was on a blower
somebody [__] blew out an engine I I
asked to make you wanted the belt I
[__] took it off where's ver he's
said nean Marcus again belts are on
sale hey I'm going to go back to room
and uh and jerk off all right dude call
me after call me after so I know you're
okay D dude be careful yeah call me
after so I know you're okay be careful
dude yeah now right after but like you
know dude I'd spot you but I just can't
I'm not buil for
it oh then you got to break into the
hotel room and that bolt thing's on and
all you see is just like two two inches
of the guy's
head oh no
Paul he finally did it oh [__] oh and I
go and see your Dead face with that what
smile what if I made what if I made it
all de what if I made it through though
and you got to call Stace you go Stace
yeah listen dude he did it again it was
back we don't know how long he was out
it's too L to know of how much brain
damage there
was me walking in you got your soft dick
in your
hand [__] breakfast sauce plck it out
PL it out oh [__] dude that is a really
[__] Wild Thing That Somebody found
out about how do you find out about that
the first guy the first [__] guy he
was probably choking his his woman
probably liked it you know she probably
f [__] put his hand on his throat you
know on her throat right oh [__] or then
maybe she was nuts maybe he was [__]
pound from up top and she [__]
grabbed his and he goes that was nuts
yeah that actually felt pretty good she
I don't want to do that anymore and then
he kind of looked
around there it is that's uh yeah D me
and my wife you know she's I'm glad I'm
out here for [__] a bunch of days
that's good have a break no I want her
to [__] feel it I want her to feel me
not there yeah you have that tiger
walking around I want her to feel yeah
yeah he's not
there he's not there feel it for a
couple weeks you know feel it for a
couple weeks I was joking with her I go
you ain't going to miss me oh no of
course I'm going to miss you you know I
love you you they don't give a [__] you
don't give they don't give a [__] they
don't give a [__] they give a [__] when
you leave but when you're there they
don't give a [__] no that mean it's just
not it's Paul we got football yeah
that's all we got did you watch that uh
that late game last night the uh the
Raiders and Steelers yeah I did man I
did and it was Garo didn't look good he
he threw two dumb ones but like dude
what about their their [__] first of
all that uh that uh Max what's face on
on uh Crosby oh dude that's an old
school defensive D he looks like he
should be on the 70s Raiders love that
guy yeah and then their their receiving
Corp right they got another D guy
Devonte Adams Devonte Adams one of the
top guys they got jacobe Myers Myers and
then they got uh Corey hul no what's his
name thr uh oh oh Renfro Hunter rro
Hunter Hunter rro I knew Hunter rro
Hunter
rro who Hunter oh Hunter Adams who's the
rro guy uh I don't know what team the
Raiders and then they got that kid on
the corner that number 26 can play like
I saw a lot of people I was like I
[__] like this team Garoppolo just
made two you know bonehead throws but
other than that you know I thought he
was I thought he was all
right yeah the Devonte what's his name
oh it is Hunter Hunter Hunter rro
Devonte what Devonte Adams Devonte Adams
the guy like [__] 100 yards by the
second quarter 15 he had 15 catches it
was unbelievable yeah but they just
couldn't get it in the end zone dude
Aaron Rogers wrote him a note the last
year he was in he was in the Packers and
he goes hey dude just want to let you
know you're the greatest that I've ever
seen do this and having you on my team
is amazing he wrote him this whole thing
and then uh after that year he went to
play with uh to the Raiders with Derek
Carr because they played at Fresno State
together Devonte Adams and Derek Carr
played at Fresno State but they shipped
Carr out and now they got this guy dude
how about the Jets quarterback man this
kid is just L dude Romo was being really
nice about it I don't know how nice he
was being he was definitely going you
got to make that throw you got you got
to get no but they were like dude guy
was late on like they were like showing
the guy open they're going yeah they
don't need to be doing that to people no
no it's like once you lose your fan base
is already giv you [__] you don't need
like the video like evidence but um I
got to tell you once again Paul that
stupid [__] prevent defense stupid
prevent defense we got the game it's
[__] over right we got him down on
like their 30 yard line and then we we
go into like this [__] 30 yard Co you
were texting me you were texting me
going dude I'm telling you this is it
but then you guys got that safety from
that that Jud out no I'm not talking
about that I'm not talking about I'm
talking about once we got the safety
they ended up because we gave him this
kid who didn't throw one long ball the
whole day no we gave him a 30 yard
completion now we had one shot at the
endzone dude they almost got it we we
knocked it down and went off his
shoulder and Jet got one hand on it and
uh Cobb almost caught it yeah Randall
Cobb almost caught it no and what the
genius of the prevent defense is it had
me watching that boring ass game to the
very last play that's it's a marketing
it's marketing it's not defense it's
[__] marketing it's designed to have
as many games end with the the team
that's losing getting four shots at the
end zone I got didn't happen last night
Jimmy threw a [__] interception but I
know it doesn't make any sense Paul it's
I know I know plus the fact that Wilson
wasn't completing any passes the entire
game until that until that drive this
guy hasn't been playing good all day he
hasn't beaten you deep the whole your
[__] safety's doing the job the
corners are doing their [__] job and
then in the end it's just like let's
make this guy look like Joe Montana
let's let him go right down the [__]
field he almost did it yeah no uh Baron
Rogers was playing oh if Aaron Rogers
was playing I think that we would have
lost the game I think you would have
lost the game 100% we would have lost
the game I don't that's the worst thing
I've seen is a quarterback of that
caliber going out four game four plays
into his [__] new team that's that's
[__] horrible that's [__] horrible
man no it's and and bad things come in
threes Okay so happened to Vinnie now it
happened to
Aaron who's who's the next quarterback
Vinnie Aaron and yeah who's another old
guy that's going to go there oh no to to
close out their career it seems like
it's all young guys now did the
Cardinals end up losing did the Cowboys
come back and beat him no cowboy no
Cardinals end up scoring again Cardinals
beat him but the Cowboys were coming
back right no but then the Cardinal
scored again I like this whole Cardinals
like [__] coming out they come out in
the first quart two quarters and they
score like [__] 25 points rich
ganon's kid
I always like seeing that remember Rich
Ganon I love Rich Ganon yeah that's his
son coaching kid looks like he just
[__] got out of math class in
10 [__] I thought you say he was
playing no his son is coaching by the
way that's what I was thinking about we
I mean we could talk about this on
anything better but [__] it we're here
coaches today I mean [__] nerds dude
skinny remember oh yeah that guy in the
Dolphins you they went from Don schula
that he looks like buddy Ryan Bill
Parcels [__] who else was a big
Chuck null or even if they were small
Tom Landry was like stoic they had like
a thing now this guy's like Dan re Dan
Reeves was another [__] squared guard
shut the [__] up even Mike Shanahan the
father Mike dika Mike dika now you got
the kid in Miami who who's friends with
Dan s that's Nick croll's cousin
doubleganger no that's what the joke is
that guy looks like Nick croll and the
guy from the bills looks like me dude
NFL coaches today look like the kid you
put that football players bullied in
high school now that the I don't the
Jets coach though he looks cool oh uh
Salah yeah dude your coach
unacceptable no but you know what he's
old school he he's there's something
about him he he's he's he's Rex Ryan how
Rex Ryan used to be like too fat yeah by
the way Rex Ryan looks like a million
bucks now yeah he's got the full head of
white hair his teeth are as white as his
hair yeah his hair is like like it isn't
like old guy white it's like vibrant re
he's got a [__] tan there's nobody
that would be more fun if me and you sat
down and drank a p an ice cold pint of
beer with Rex Ryan that guy would be
[__] make us cry laughing you know he
has Marina Vibe like I feel like he's
out on a boat a lot he's all tanned up
he comes on there with like Randy Moss
he's in a good [__] mood he's picking
games yeah dude he doesn't give a he's
like why would you ever go back to
coaching I don't think he will oh
another one we missed Bill Cower dude
Bill Cower with the the chin and that
was a [__] coach that you would oh
you know one of the old school guys the
Steelers guy they got now Mike uh Tomlin
yeah he's old school yep he's old school
Mike tomin you know he was my favorite
NFL coach and then I saw him at the
Knicks game and we were in like the same
thing and people and he was just being
like like not rude to people and he just
walked by like hey what's up coach and
he just [__] walked by and I get it
but I was just like he wasn't friendly
to anybody and then somebody else said
something he was like I don't know you
like you know he's one of those it's
like meanwhile John Maybe doesn't like
New
Yorkers I actually respect game huh he
was at the Knicks game rooting for him
he was rooting for the Knicks M who are
they playing we were in the playoffs we
were playing I think that was the
Cavs I think you know he was there with
Nick I'm I'm just [__] with I have no
idea yeah get me I would think if you're
that famous if you're going to the you
just got to settle in like like all
right I'm walking into this everybody's
gonna be there just say hello and take
the pictures Frank Sina just got really
mad in this interview I saw him he goes
now why he goes why wouldn't you do that
it was it was [__] and it was like
Sinatra in the 70s he had the uh he had
the blue sweater that Piscopo he had the
blue sweater that Piscopo actually had
in uh Ebony and Ivory sketch with Eddie
Murphy and he just goes now I know I
know some guys they don't want to be
bothered he goes now why wouldn't you do
that why wouldn't you do that he goes it
makes you feel good it makes them feel
good you're making somebody happy you
stop you sign the autograph and then you
go why wouldn't you do that and I was
like am I am I I'm like yeah yeah but he
existed in a different time of being
famous right it wasn't like Frank Frank
Frank Frank can you call my cousin can
you call
my let me tell you
something dude one of the best [__]
Sinatra stories ever is that [__] guy
when he went to Australia some feminist
over there gave him a bad review cuz you
know of course she did well you know
here's lyrics were a little dated at
that point you know whatever so feminism
was coming up or whatever they were
burning their bras whatever dumb [__]
they were doing right so she gave him a
bad review and then he called her at the
uh Sydney Opera house there's a
recording of it I can't f i was tell me
he [__] her dude no
that that would have been [__] nuts
dude I don't know if this story could
talk
that tell me [__] the
dude
um he [__] uh
what the [__] was I gonna say he uh he
he called her a $3
whore3 [__] wait at the at the show at
the show and then it got out and then
there was this big backlash so the Prime
Minister was saying you have to
apologize to her and he's like I'm not
apologizing so then they came back and
said if you don't apologize we're not
going to allow you to leave the country
so now he's holed up and his penous
suite and he says to his lawyer as he's
pouring a drink he goes well I'm not
apologizing so now what and it was like
the Cuban Missile Crisis they were just
sitting up there they figured out some
wiggle room where they could both be
happy and he end up leaving and then he
came back he's like I'm never going back
to that [__] piece of [__] country
again is that right oh that's great he
was mad I'm sure he went back that's
[__] great $3 [__] oh dude yeah
Frankie must have cleaned up dude oh
when Frankie walked in a room yeah hey
am I supposed to read this
advertising okay all right let me let me
do a read here Paul let's get it you got
time you got time for quick cigar
what quick cigar you know I mean who am
I I I'm 20 heyy Paul Who Am I who am I
yeah who am I to
[__] don't threaten me with a good
time hey Paul it's policy genius holy
know yeah Paul let me tell you from
personal experience it is super
satisfying to check life insurance off
your to-do list it is a good
thing Paul's choking himself up uh and
getting covered oh my God can you get
life insurance listen before I sign this
like listen I don't want oh [__] I don't
want to be forward here but I [__]
you know I like to tie a belt around my
neck and jerk off like if I accidentally
that's not considered suicide cuz it's
by accident I'm not trying to kill
myself I'm dude that's that's how you
beat the life insurance where they don't
cover suicide you just got to deal with
the humiliation you're going to send
your
family is you just put your dick in your
hand and then really hang yourself and
then they call it auto orotic affixation
and you you get you you get the payout
your family's got to move sorry about
that I'll clean that up in a second all
right um and getting covered can be even
more satisfying than autoerotic aixi
when you use policy genius policy genius
knows how valuable your time is Paul
that's why their technology makes it
easy to compare life insurance quotes
from Top America's top insurers in just
a few clicks to find your lowest price
with policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just
292 bucks per year for a million dollars
of coverage some options offer same da
approval and avoid unnecessary medical
exam how is it unnecessary what if
you're [__] as big as a house they
wouldn't want to ensure that policy
genius has licens award-winning agents
who can help you find the best fit for
your needs they work for you Paul not
the insurance companies that means they
don't have an incentive to recommend one
insurer over another so you can trust
their guidance uh policy changes for
parents caregivers anyone else who has
to depend on them they simp they
simplify the process of getting life
insurance so you can protect the people
you love no wonder they have thousands
of fstar reviews on Google and Trust P
pilot Paul your loved ones deserve a
financial safety net you deserve a
smarter way to find and buy it head to
policygenius.com or click the link in
the description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's policygenius.com p o l
i Cy GE n i u s .c all right Paul that's
the podcast can I plug some [__] no
let's do
that let's [__] let's get after it
what you're GNA be down what do you got
what you got huh uh I got a big one I
got a big one for me I got a big one for
me man this is the first uh I will be I
announced it last week uh pre-sale
actually pre-sale is over but tickets
are available now first time ever
headlining New Year's Eve New York City
grammar C theater uh so get in there
it's going to be great I'm bringing big
he's made the big time I'm the theater
in New York oh I'm bringing some up
doing the town oh you know that it's
going we're going to have belts in the
green room now go home and get your joke
book
uh I don't know if you heard I don't
know no more no more featuring no no no
more featuring I don't know they didn't
they didn't come into to LA to tell you
um no I'm doing the grammar C theater
December 31st um when does this come out
this Thursday oh dude uh San Diego
American Comedy Company October 6th and
7th four shows uh Philadelphia helium
20th and 21st M uh and then I will be
they changed my Harford Connecticut date
I'm in Harford Connecticut not on the
1st of November but October 13th I'll be
in Albany uh I'll be at the Funny Bone
in Albany OH at that big mall Bill I'm
going to be in a mall see uh in Albany I
when I used to do that Albany what was
it no no I used to do Syracuse no
there's a there's a just like a gigantic
thing in a mall it's like like Levity
Live it's I us do the egg oh yeah I did
the egg I did the egg on New Year's once
too um that's a cool place that's on
November 2nd but check out New Year's
Eve guys and I'm going to be making an
announcement about my special which Paul
is going to be shooting in Chicago
speaking of uh oh I love it yeah I love
it all right I got a couple here yeah uh
October 1st Springfield Massachusetts at
the Mass Mutual Center 104 good buddy
October 4th University Park Pennsylvania
Bryce Jordan Center and then on October
7th Paul I'm in Canton Ohio you know
that football stadium when they they
play the game every year yeah yeah
they're turning that they like [__]
turning that into comedy Place uh Tom
Benson Hall of Fame stadium and then on
the 28th for all you animals I'm going
to be up in Reno Nevada with Joe bartnik
oh my god oh yeah oh Reno's been waiting
for us uh that's on October 28th there's
something about bartnik and Reno that
just makes so much [__] sense Goes
Down Smooth
oh all right that is the podcast this is
Paul ver check him out New Year's Eve at
gramy theater in new I've ever done yeah
this I'm not going to lie this this dude
is uh he's coming Paul is coming he has
established himself he's made his
presence be known and now he he's on the
way up didn't skip any steps Paul no
didn't skip any steps it's all it's all
[__] built in Bedrock it's up to code
yeah tell my [__] wife I'm
kidding tell my [__] wife you said
tell my [__] wife I'm kidding it was
all one sentence tell my [__] I'm
just kidding sweetie yeah I love just
Kidd I got the change out I was feeling
it all right Paul ver everybody uh enjoy
your weekend enjoy your weekend I will
talk to you
[Music]
later hey what's going on it's Bill bur
and it's time for the Monday Morning
podcast for Monday September
28th 2015 what's going on how are you
how's it going oh
yeah [__] burned out uh just got back
from the road oh what a tour I had what
a lovely wonderful time I had going all
the way through uh Texas I want to thank
everybody who came out to the shows this
week uh we had an awesome time probably
too much fun if you know what I mean um
and when I say that I mean I'm on my way
back The pendulum's Swinging back the
other way for me to become a fat pasty
toted jackass again however I am uh I'm
going to nip it in the uh is it in the
butt is it in the bud you know you
nipping something in the butt like a dog
bites some somebody in the ass or you
are you pruning a [__] flower I have
no idea but what I do know is that I'll
get a 100 emails telling me how [__]
dumb I am um been getting a bunch of
those lately Jesus Christ the [__]
critics out there
you [__] are just I'm just
taking they're just taking my goddamn
knees out lately you
know did I ever say I was smart I don't
think I
did I don't I don't know what their
problem is oh I know what their problem
is yeah they probably didn't go after
what they wanted in life and now they're
[__] miserable so they just sit
around
going do you know some jerkov sent me an
email he actually counted how many times
me and Paul ver said dude it was one of
the saddest things I ever heard why the
[__] would you I count it over a hundred
times that's what you did that's what
you did with a half hour of your life
you [__]
dope some people people you just want to
[__] shake them by their
shoulders good Lord turn it off then I
do want to apologize for the levels man
I know I [__] it up last time uh you
know it's this weird thing where the
levels can be completely way too high
but if in the headphones you don't hear
it you know that's what you have a mixer
for it's actually what you have a sound
guy for and I don't have one um so I
apologize for that um but I think it was
very fitting that the podcast on
Thursday in an audio sense was
completely [__] up and for some of you
in a verbal
sense um anyways I think uh you know if
you saw the the [__] abuse that we
did last week to our bodies I don't know
what my [__] problem is I I couldn't
[__]
stop I couldn't stop like every night I
would be dragging ass getting ready to
go do my show going dude what the [__]
am I doing then the second you go out on
stage the adrenaline starts going you
get a couple laughs you feel [__]
great right and then literally the first
show halfway through it I'll just just
be thinking like I can have a beer
tonight I'll have one I'll have one then
I'll go to bed and it'll be fine the
next thing you know you walk in the
Streets of San Antonio and the [__]
security guard at the Alamo tells you to
get the [__] out of there you know as
ver is running
around ver goes take a picture of me in
front of the Alamo right and I you got
to know that right now how [__] drunk
we are walking around like a couple of
dopes with smoking cigar of course right
let's go let's go over and smoke a cigar
in front of the [__] Alamo you know
why not do that why why learn about the
history um we actually ended up learning
about the history cuz verie went over
and he goes dude take a picture of me in
front of the Alamo for some reason
there's this security guard working late
night he goes hey you can't do that you
can't do that so ver goes take the
picture and he rips his shirt off and
makes this absolutely psycho look on his
face just to get the [__] security
guard going it's like what do you mean
we can't can't do that why can't we
can't take a picture of the [__]
Alamo is it after hours so then he comes
up and he thinks we're a couple of drunk
[__] which we
are right you got to see the picture of
verie I sent it to him maybe he'll put
it online I'm going to leave it up to
him but dude I have to tell you Paul ver
is one of the most happiest go-lucky
people I've ever seen in my life and he
looks like a [__] serial killer like
I saw the photo and I said to him I was
like dude if this picture was was the
poster of a movie I would go see it
immediately you look like a [__]
lunatic um so anyways the guy comes over
and he starts talking to us and
immediately we just start asking him
questions about the Alamo and he
couldn't resist he couldn't resist and
he started telling us all this
information and I was sitting there
going like well no wonder all the guys
died look how small the wall
is that's like even smaller than that
thing that people have to run up on and
at the end of the American Ninja Warrior
you know if anything would [__] me
over on that show as long as you had a
decent halfway decent thing you could
figure you could work the grip strength
up right right if they had like a a
approaching 50 years old American Ninja
Warrior obstacle course I feel like I I
could work my way up to get through it
but there's nothing helping there's
nothing helping my I got white guy
disease you know what I mean white guys
we got those meaty CS they weigh us down
you know what I mean we need those
[__] deer
legs we just don't have them we got big
dumb meaty calvs our calvs are like
[__] they're like ankle weights I
don't know what it is but there's no
[__] way I could ever get over there
so I'm sitting there looking at the wall
at the Alamo going like dude I swear to
God I feel like I could do a run plant
one foot Midway up the wall and I think
I got a shot I got a shot man I could go
right up and over what's up there Daniel
Boone what do you say there Sam Houston
where's Davey Crockett huh what about
that guy who settled Virginia and banged
the Indian woman and then they shaved
his head and they made him one of them
right then they murdered everybody but
him what was his name what was it Eddie
Virginia I know it has something to do
with
Virginia Tim
Richmond the [__] was his
name Michael West
Virginia
um Town what the [__] was that guy's
name had the first settlement down there
in Virginia I know there's a city or
there's a street named after him isn't
there that guy [__] did it right
right he landed there and immediately
interacted [__] started banging one
of the natives that's what you do you
assimilate he was like oh yeah is that
how you make corn that's
fantastic show up with a belt buckle on
your hat I mean you think you're not
going to get scalped you [__] dope
standing there with your white socks
like you're going to do the Billy Jean
moonwalk across the [__] plane you
know what's funny did they even dress
like
that you know how much of of what you
think is actual history is actually just
what the first people in Hollywood did
when they made movies you know what I
mean and then that just became like oh
this is this is what it was you know
like I always do the classic when they
talk about the uh Native Americans and
playing drums and they always do
that
that was completely made up by a white
guy there is no there's not one shred of
evidence in fact one of my brothers one
time took a tour someplace I don't know
in Arizona and the guy was talking about
Indians in in uh Native Americans sorry
in percussion right and
uh and he was going he was showing some
of the ways that they would play the
drums he goes they would do it this way
they do it this way they do it that way
y y y he goes but at no point did they
ever
go and the whole he he killed he crushed
got an Applause break the whole place
started laughing because there was a
bunch of white people I imagine going oh
yeah that's what we that's what we
thought they
did so anyways let me get back to where
the [__] I was at so we're at the
goddamn
Alamo
right and
um we start talking to this guy he tells
the whole [__] story man Jesus Christ
it was brutal oh really bill was the
massacre there BR you know you until
you're actually there you're looking at
it and you're standing on the grounds of
it cuz what killed me is what what
they've left of the fort was the inner
perimeter so where we were standing
disrespectfully taking silly photos was
where a lot of people died they just
took down the wall that was around the
fort so what we were looking at was this
inner area you know where probably the
officers you know took advantage of the
women that were there whatever the [__]
happened back in the 1800s I don't know
and basically what happens when they
showed up was they um they just [__]
killed every guy there even if you gave
up they just lined you up and shot you
and as [__] up as that was I always
think
back to whoever lost the
war you know which I'm going on a limb
here saying it was
Mexico because I have no idea CU they
never talked they know they never talked
about the [__] I don't even know when
it happened to be honest with you I
didn't take the tour like I said I was
drunk with a cigar
so um I mean it wasn't like the Spanish
American war didn't that take place in
like the
Philippines some [__] up like I don't
even know this is [__] hilarious cuz
every history class I took when I
was I'm just laughing now thinking of
you guys rolling your eyes how
embarrassed youed should be embarrassed
as an American that yet again I'm doing
this and this could go out to anybody
outside of our borders um I should get
audited right now for not knowing this
[__] um they would always start with
1492 Columbus sail the ocean blue and
then the pilgrims and then they get
through the Revol evolutionary War maybe
the War of 1812 you'd get up to that and
then they stopped and they just kept
going back to it every [__] year just
hammering that [__] into your head
Thomas Jefferson I could not tell a lie
completely ignored the genocide of the
Native Americans completely ignored
slavery just ignored all of it just
every [__] year going back to the
goddamn powdered wigs I [__] hated it
and then when I finally got to
uh I finally got to high school I took
this honors history class cuz I actually
liked history and then we did ancient
medieval history holy
[__] that might have been the most
boring stuff oh I just remember the
cover of the book had this ancient
medieval broken plate on it it almost
looks like that stupid that that dish
they give women when they win Wimbledon
which always cracked me up you know what
I mean they give a guy a chalice to
drink [__] wine out of he gets blown
by a hooker and a woman wins Wimbleton
they give her a late yeah why don't you
go make some biscuits there
sweetheart I'm surprised feminist groups
haven't complained like why don't we get
a trophy why do we get that deviled egg
[__] plate you know what I
mean I don't know maybe it's considered
a plaque the [__] do I know I thought
the Spanish American war happened in the
Philippines I know we went over the
Philippines at some point we did some
sort of
damage um but could I find it on a map
actually I could cuz I've been to
Singapore right it was east of it it was
east of
Singapore um if I remember correctly oh
yes I've I've spread my ignorance around
the globe so anyways we're there and the
guy was talking about you know how they
they they let the women and children
live but they completely just killed
every guy there even if you
surrendered even if you were running
away from the fourth they just shot you
in the back and I just was thinking like
yeah man I mean that's what you got to
do like whoever that Commander was Santa
Monica whatever the [__] his name was
Santa something or Santa Cruz San Jose I
think it was a city but it was actually
a guy it was like his last name I think
even California had to give it up being
like you know what that [__] was
going hard I know that's not his name
and I don't have time to look it up
because that would involve research all
right so you just [__] sit there in
your cubicle and you listen to this how
dare you judge me in my ignorance it's
just said there at your job making money
not doing your [__] job how dare you
uh maybe listening to it in your
car I don't know what you're doing so
anyways I always think that like that's
how hard like I when I think about you
know if I was a Native American and I
knew forget that if you knew if they
knew there we go there's the [__]
right pronoun right is that a pronoun or
is it an adverb
um if they knew what the [__] was going
to go down can you imagine
that'd be a great series of films just
called if they knew right and all about
history about horrific wrongs that were
done about one group of people to
another you know and you know how each
one of them would start every little
clip of if they knew would start with a
bunch of white people come pulling up in
a
boat oh who are these people hey
everybody next you know you're enslaved
or you're [__] you know just getting
murdered I always thought about if they
knew like the Native
Americans what the [__] they would they
would I swear to God they would have all
joined forces like in the Warriors can
you dig it right and what they would
have to
do okay is they would have to let
everybody come ashore right and this is
what you do at night you slip onto the
boat boats and you you kill everybody
who's on the boat so now there's no
Escape all right and then you'd have to
murder everybody men women children all
of them you'd have to murder all of them
all right then once all of that was done
one group of people okay is in charge
you got to take those bodies and you
have to drag those
[__] hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of miles Inland and you got a
bury them when no one's ever going to
find them all right and then meanwhile
another group of people has to
systematically begin dismantling those
ships all right so that the belief would
be that they never made it to the shores
of
America
right no that wouldn't work because they
just keep sending more in the boats
would get
better I was trying to think like how
could the Native Americans stopped what
happened at some
point oh I know what you do you [__]
you'd have to keep the weapons why would
you take apart the boat bill you [__]
dope no keep the
boat all right [__] that let's let's
back up here still kill everybody on
land still drag him a [__] couple
hundred miles Inland still bury him all
right kill everybody on the boat except
for like five six people and then you go
listen [__] if you don't teach
us how to drive this goddamn thing all
right we're going to [__] I don't
know we're going to do something to you
that's going to be really painful all
right I don't you somehow you you get
them to teach you how to drive the boat
and once you get the boat right you
start breaking down
uh I don't know the cannonballs and [__]
I don't know how you do it you just have
to keep killing these
[__] no maybe the best way to
do it is that they don't know you know
what I don't have a [__] solution God
damn it white people are [__] evil
huh even me as a white person you think
I could figure out how to stop
us you know what I got to get back to
youy you if you guys got any suggestions
how you could have stopped that but it
is you have to do what they're doing to
you what they're going to do to you
first that's the only way to do it you
know what I mean people come over right
they got a better pistol than you do
right and they think that God thinks
what's that what they're doing is right
yeah it's [__] over
there's not going to be the only time I
ever [__] saw the indigenous people
survived when a boatload of white people
showed up was in New Zealand all right
and if you saw the the the the people
who are indigenous in New Zealand every
one of them I swear to God is built like
a Hall of Fame
linebacker like and I'm not just talking
about and like they look like listen
this dude could change the [__] game
and white people pulled up and were just
like all right uh you know what let's
we're going to be here with you and
we're going to kind of like share this
area I mean I was only in New Zealand
for like three [__] days but that's
what I was
told uh while drinking in a bar it might
be wrong it might be right you know
hopefully it's wrong because uh you know
somebody can count how many words I
[__] used
incorrectly oh yeah why if I I don't
think I've ever done that
if I have't counted
words I don't know maybe maybe people
are into that bill you know why does
everybody have to do what you do you
douche all right go [__]
yourself trying to find this oh my god
with the [__] notification thing you
know something apple with this whole
[__] where they just have this new thing
where they sync everything and you can't
delete the app and go [__] yourself this
is how it's going to be do you guys
realize myself included that we are
allowing the [__] nerds at Apple to
grab Us by the back of our necks and
shove our face into dog [__] and just we
basically gave up some freedoms on this
this new round with the with the the
iPhone 6 and their new their uh new
Macbook Air thing that I bought here you
know as I sit there paying the [__]
person who's probably looking at me
through that little video camera right I
just gave him the finger huh you like
that I'm a rebel you know I'm stopping
what's going
on
um I don't I just I resent the whole
thing dude my my my level of being a
maniac with control being a control
freak do you know when I was in San
Antonio um I believe you were at Trinity
College like every [__] gig was just
like wake up drive four hours get in the
hotel shower put your gig clothes on go
down do the gig and leave and half the
[__] places I didn't even know where
the hell I was at but uh but the shows
are all shows are awesome I tell you
right now I [__] love Texas and [__]
everybody who says all the bad [__]
about it I love those people down there
man [__] good time um and I only had
one [__] guy only one
Maniac that really just said something
really ugly uh when I was on stage which
was I thought was pretty good I was
doing this thing about Caitlyn Jenner
and this guy in the upper deck just goes
[__] that [__] science
experiment or something like that I was
just like wow right but you know what's
great I got like 20 emails some people
from Houston that were going how
embarrassed they were and hoping that I
wasn't going to judge Houston like that
you know what I mean of course they
didn't yell out while that was going on
because uh when people are dumb to that
level it's really
loud I don't know why look at me I'm
dumb I'm really loud you know but the
Dumber you get the louder you get right
and then people who know it's [__]
they just kind of said well that's
embarrassing they just kind of send an
email a few people yelled shut shut the
[__] up I don't know what happened that
was the only thing other than that you
know the way people especially out in
Hollywood the way they look at you know
their [__] elitist goddamn attitudes
out here I swear to God I swear to God I
thought I was liberal till I came out of
here I cannot [__] stand the politics
that out here they are so [__] it's
literally Fox News to the left they are
as [__] ridiculous as anybody you've
ever seen on who's that [__] chick
who looks like she needs some iron in
her system whatever it is she's got like
Gray skin me and D Roa used to always
talk about her she sounds like she
manages wrestlers like what she says is
so over the top whatever obviously it's
all the way to the right but out here in
Hollywood you get that to the left it's
as [__]
ridiculous and um they think they're
just just as right
um I don't know I I I just I I do not
enjoy political conversation out here is
not a fun thing to be involved in you
know what I mean we just put it that way
so anyways
the [__] was I talking
about ah there you go again bill you
know you go in these [__] tangents
and you forget what the hell you're
talking about back it up here Bill where
the [__] you were at the Alamo then you
did the run through
Texas Trinity College some about Trinity
oh yeah yeah control freak thing right
so we're coming out of [__] Trinity
College and as we're coming out it's one
of these old school venues where they
used to build these venues and then
there was just it there was one way in
and one way out so it was going to be
horrific just you know it reminds me way
back back in the day when they they uh
when they first made great Woods in
Mansfield Massachusetts I don't know
what it's called now I saw Eddie Murphy
there on the raw Tour by the way had
lawn seats The Weather Girls opened up
it's one of my great I saw Stevie Ray
vongh there I saw so many [__]
amazing shows there I saw Rodney
Dangerfield Jesus I'm old um
anyways I saw Burt
Lancaster um what was I saying here so
the big thing about about that venue was
everybody was excited that they built it
cuz all these great bands were going
there but for some [__] reason they
they had like it was like a driveway you
know so over the course of the day like
20,000 [__] people would show up
driving through this one entrance and
there was already traffic but at the end
all 20,000 Tred to get out at the same
time and remember the local radio
stations would do these hilarious bits
about people uh still there and not
being able to get to work you know so
anyway so this is one of these types of
venues uh except it only held like 300
people [__] you but still you know what
I mean it was going to be brutal trying
to get out of there so we're running out
of there I jump in the car with ver and
there's already people you know running
out to try to do what I'm doing so as
we're sitting there I want to bang a
right when I get out of the driveway to
go exactly where I came from and the
cops telling me he sees my directional
and he wants me to he wants me to go
left so I'm trying to go right and he
Blows the Whistle points right at me and
then points to the direction he wants me
to go to and I [__] got so mad I
[__] pointed right at him I pointed
right back at him I was like [__] you
you duus I yelled at him pointing at him
fortunately my headlights were on it was
dark out so he couldn't see it and I
turned to the left and you know what was
funny was it ended up being the proper
way to go out it was it it was like a
dream it was like melted butter he was
actually doing me a favor um and not
steering me into I swear to God if you
saw the look on ver face just looking at
me like dude what the [__] is wrong with
you and uh the only I think redeemable
quality that I have about my personality
is uh when I do [__] like that and
somebody looks at me I can I at least am
immature enough to be like yeah I know
dude I
know I'm a [__] Moody psychopath I
know you don't even have to say anything
I see it on your face I know you're
right [__] [__] but you know you got
a [__] point and the whistle
you
know all right so I was wrong oh [__]
you guys all right let's do some
advertising for this week um all right
let's plow ahead here uh I was oh you
know what we went to we went to Texas
OSU on uh Saturday and um I got to tell
you man I I've been such a huge fan of
the Longhorns my whole life man I just
loved I just was [__] it was a great
mascot great colors I started watching
them back when like Jerry gray was um
one of their big um all-americans I
remember he went with the Rams if I if I
was correct I was just a fan of him and
I thought he was [__] great player I
missed Earl
Campbell but
um they were always good Texas football
was always the [__] so I always wanted
to go and as I mentioned before I think
I told this last time I I always wanted
to go and I booked myself at the Cap
City comedy club and they were playing
Missouri in the afternoon I was going to
do the show at night and then and I was
all excited I bought tickets I was ready
to go and then what ended up happening
was uh Texas and Missouri were both 4-0
and the flex scheduled moved the game to
like 8:00 at night or 7:00 at night so
not only did I not get to go to the game
nobody showed up nobody showed up to my
[__] show and um so I finally got to
go and um I'd like to thank uh Dudley
from The Dudley and Bob show who hooked
me up with uh with some tickets and
South by Southwest Festival they also
I'm sorry the moon tower Festival
the moon tower Festival also hooked me
up with tickets I ended up with more
tickets than I needed and I was actually
able to hook up with some some other
friends that I've made in Austin and uh
oh man it was great dude and I got to
thank Luke and all his friends for
reaching out to me on Twitter and uh me
and verie showed up we drove up from San
Antonio
right um oh dude we had the best [__]
time drove up got a small breakfast cuz
we knew this kid Luke was was going to
be smoking whatever the [__] he was
going to be smoking and uh we showed up
at their tailgate you know threw some
money in we brought some [__] we brought
some biscuits in from uh the Czech
Bakery
um that it's somewhere it's near Waco
Texas whenever you go from if you ever
Drive Dallas to Austin or vice versa
when you're on the I think it's is it
the 35 or the
45 whatever the one that's it's further
left if you're looking at a map uh there
there's a place out there called the uh
the cze bakery and just I'm not even
going to describe it just [__] go in
there and get yourself one of their
breakfast sandwiches it's [__] insane
it's [__] insane every time I drive
down there and you walk in there and
you're like I'm just going to get one
and then you walk in and next thing you
know you're getting three and splitting
a fourth one with whoever the [__]
you're with and you hate yourself
afterwards but it's delicious so I we I
I bought a bunch of [__] from there you
know some sauerkraut and biscuits and
stuff to add to it and we showed up and
this dude Luke was making uh
he was smoking sausage wrapped in
chicken wrapped in
bacon all right and then his side he had
sweet potatoes with this uh this butter
that he made that had bourbon in it and
like brown sugar for the sweet potatoes
dude it was that butter on the potato I
was joking when I was eating it I was
like I feel like I'm like getting buzzed
and I'm going to have a heart attack at
the same time it's one of the greatest
things I've ever tasted then he actually
had a hearty Co sloth is anything worse
than the [__] milky [__] it's all
watering down spilling into all the good
food he had the Hardy kind [__]
delicious and then they had a peach
cobbler that had uh peach and Cherry in
it and um dude it was [__]
outstanding I tried to pick a you know a
couple of tips up on smoking meat and
everything but he actually had a smoker
so that's completely different than the
the Big Green Egg my problem has been
keeping the fire going going so I
actually had a uh a podcast listener
reach out who has a big green egg was
nice enough to send me a long email
about some stuff so I'm going to try to
smoke some ribs on Wednesday you know
I'm just going to keep doing it till I
[__] get it down but anyway so we met
a bunch of people there and fie said the
funniest [__] thing we were standing
there is we're is we're eating the food
it's like so good we're like Whispering
going oh my god dude this is [__]
unreal and ver goes like he goes dude I
think people in the South are just
inherently better at cookouts or
barbecues whatever you want and we would
I was joking with one of the guys there
was saying like because of the [__]
we're growing up in the Northeast we can
only cook out for like you know whatever
five months five and a half months out
of the year and then the rest of the
time is just too goddamn
uh it's just too goddamn cold or the
weather's just too [__] bad so every
year the South people in the warmer
clients just they just increased the Gap
um but it was just [__] delicious
right and uh so we end up going to the
game and uh I'm rooting for Texas of
course and uh I got to tell you
something man I think I'm a [__]
Jinx I just realized that since I
started going to these big college games
every year the home team has never
won all right the last time it happened
I went to a game I went to a Georgia
Bulldog game in like September was some
cupcake game I can't even remember who
the [__] they played all right but since
then all right this year it was Texas
OSU Texas I'll just name all the teams
who they played the first teams the
whole team all right Texas OSU [__]
OSU wins all right last year I went to
Miami Florida state Florida State one
the year before I went to LSU Al no LSU
uh no no Texas A&M Alabama Alabama one
the year before that I went to LSU
Alabama and Alabama one
again and then the year before that I
went to the cotton bow which is neutral
ground for the Longhorns in Oklahoma
they played the Red River game there I
went to that game rooted for Texas bet
on Texas and Oklahoma smoked
them so that is 1 2 3
4 5 is that five games I'm like 0 and
five so I I got to break the streak I'm
almost not going to say who the [__] I'm
going to next year because oh I got it
no in a couple weeks I'm going to Notre
Dame USC Notre Dame's the home team and
I am rooting for Notre Dame all right me
and ver were joking because ver has been
to all those games with me I was saying
we're like that guy in the mush in a
bronx tail so my apology to uh all
Longhorn fans for going to that game and
rooting for you guys and I'd like to
some thank you
letters from some Cowboy fans they at
OSU dude I got to tell you man that was
such a brutal game to [__] watch and
you could feel it you could feel it was
going to happen dude Texas won that game
like six [__] times and then they
lost it it was unreal man every time
they they they could put him away they
just let him back into the game and that
final [__] play I don't like making
fun of college kids when they don't uh
when they [__] up because they're not
professionals yet so I'm not going to
name any names but uh that last
offensive play I guess special teams
play there literally should have been
like Benny Hill music playing I it just
all they had to do was kick the ball
away they still had to hold him you
can't break it down to one [__] play
I mean God knows that pass underneath
was there for them all [__] day and
they had no answer for it
um I don't you think if you score two
defensive touchdowns in a game your
defense gave you 14 points You' think
you could win the [__] game and they
somehow in the end they hike the ball
the punter dropped the ball and then
he's running with the ball he goes to
kick it you know goes a mile in the air
but it only went like two yards before
it went out of bounds and at that point
it looked like it was going to go into
overtime and it's like well at least
maybe they still have a chance to at
least win this game that they already
won six times in overtime and then that
play
happens and OSU got the ball and I think
they ran it like one time just to
position it and then they just kicked
the [__] ball
and uh I think that was it or maybe they
kicked it off with one second left and
it was over it was [__] brutal but um
but I got to say long run fans are great
man they weren't like
uh you know college fans are different
man when shit's not going well they're
not as at least at the stadium they act
like Class Acts I didn't hear a lot of
uh screaming about the coach or anything
so anyway so we end up going back to the
tailgate and uh I forgot to tell you
guys me and ver like just out of sheer
boredom
of driving 4 hours every [__]
day uh we were uh driving down from
Dallas to San Antonio I think that day
and that was like a 4 and a half hour
drive with the traffic and [__] and we
were trying to write a country
song and uh we came up with this country
song uh we just like all right so what
cuz we all the there was a bunch of
country stations so we kept shutting off
the radio we turn or we turn the station
and have the sound down go to a new
country station be like all right what's
song about is it about heart
heartache uh Country Road or America and
we just that was what we that's how we
were killing time so then just using
that formula we started writing this
country song and we came up
with we came up with the chorus anyways
of a country of a hit country song now
granted we can't sing but if we got like
Travis trit or somebody you
know like uh you know with some sort of
skills we think that's could be a hit so
we came up with the song basically went
America First every other place is the
worst R to be in a [__] hearse then
to live in another
country that was basically the
chorus and we were right in the I know
it's terrible but well [__] you we're
driving four hours in the middle of
Texas what are we going to do there's
nothing to say he just [__] driving
endlessly right so we were coming up go
right now we can come up with the verses
we just like well she's been to Paris
and he's been to Rome and you've been to
London but that ain't home to
me I can't remember when we somehow get
that's why I say America First every
other place is worse that's right every
other place is worse not the worst ver
he kept getting on of it so anyway so we
we come out of the game and you know
we're drunk right as you do and uh we
show back up at the T gate we say
goodbye to Luke and all those guys and
uh we get our cigars and we a couple of
drinks so then we're standing there we
don't have a ride back cuz we cabbed it
over and we're both old men so neither
one of us has the [__] Uber app on
our
uh on our phones and there's like no
taxis left so we're just sort of
stranded at the UT campus just laughing
smoking cigars and as people were
walking by verie starts telling them hey
hey excuse excuse me uh me and my buddy
here we got a number one country song on
iTunes we're really excited about it
we're just trying to get a little word
of mouth going cuz the numbers are going
down would it be okay if we sing the
chorus to you right and I'm thinking
what the [__] is he doing but he did it
so I'm like God we got to do it so it'
be like groups of like you know four or
five people these UT girls and we were
sitting there hammered with cigars
totally committed going America First
and immediately they'd have a worried
look on their face every other place is
worse rather to be in a [__] horse
and then we get to the end to live in
another country and we go country you
had to bring your your chin down to your
chest and then ye and you brought it
up that was it was either that part
would make us laugh or the [__]
hearse
um and we bombed with it man these girls
were just walking away shaking their
heads or just laughing and
uh then there was this one dude walked
by man this guy was [__] hilarious he
came walking by he's by
himself this Latino dude right big guy
and he's like all man he goes I'll
listen to that he takes his headphones
off and we start singing it and he
immediately gets a smirk on his face and
then we start laughing and then all
three was just great all three of us for
laughing and he couldn't tell if he was
serious not he just knew it was [__]
stupid um I know it's probably one of my
favorite times of the trip and then
finally this absolute [__] sweetheart
stopped and she was so nice and we sang
the whole thing I actually felt bad
about cursing that's how nice she was
and then like as we were singing it like
three times she went
oh oh
like like it was
nice she was so nice in the end then she
just goes like oh no that was good that
was good you know we find out we go what
do you do for a living you know what I
swear to God she was a social worker she
just was a big-hearted encouraging
person she was so like [__] such a
sweetheart we were like standing on the
other side of like this little stone
wall so we wouldn't freak you know a
couple guys standing in a wooded area
going hey ladies ladies it's kind of
creepy at night so we we're on the other
side of a wall to give a little bit of a
barrier so we could get people to
actually stop ver actually walked around
she was such a sweetheart he walked
around to the other side of the wall and
gave her a hug
um anyway so so that's what we did you
know that was Texas and then I went on
to uh America first that's going to be
in your head I'm telling you somebody
out there with some Talent
man trying to think of some of the other
lyrics we came up
with was something like I
like pickup trucks and ponytails
shooting fuzzy Critters no shooting
little Curtis with fuzzy
Tails sitting in a tree for covering in
dear your run I can't remember how it
goes we would every we would come up
with
uh whatever we were killing a [__]
drive what do you want from me but if
you know if you guys want to flush that
thing out I don't give a I don't know
what I'm talking about anymore
um can you tell I'm also reading right
now how easily I get [__] distracted
have I talked NFL football
yet suck it suck it suck it New England
Patriots I caught the end of the game uh
missed the entire [__] game as always
I missed the whole [__] game I was
flying up to
Toronto so uh I was hilarious when I
landed I get my uh the guy picking me up
right I jump in I'm going what's going
he go hey man I just realized it was Sun
IO did you guys get NFL football up here
and he was like what I go NFL football
you know like Patriots Cowboys Steelers
you get American football up here and
he's look at me in the rear ofie mirror
and he just goes
no I just start laughing I'm like God
right man forget it but when I got to my
hotel room they had it on I actually had
the Buffalo Bills Network cuz I was in
Toronto which was really cool seeing
their local shows and that type of thing
and seeing them all wanted to you know
rebound from the heartache loss to uh to
the Patriots and Jesus Christ did they
ever oh my
God they absolutely [__] raped the
Dolphins yesterday and um as did the
Patriots with the
Jaguars so uh like I said
man we play them again I'm still calling
it man I still think that that could go
uh I don't know for some reason I just
think if if you have a good defense and
then if you play a team two times in a
year you usually split it would really
be great to beat Rex Ryan twice so then
you know to listen to him talk [__]
again but that's what makes him great
though the fact that even though he has
a mediocre team I'm still worried about
beating him I was like we got to beat
this guy so he doesn't talk a bunch of
[__] um he's [__] great he's like a
oneman uh promotional team there but um
I didn't watch many other games I uh by
then I had to go out and
um go do my show I caught a little bit
of the late
game uh the Sunday night game or did I I
can't even [__] remember but I wish
I'd watch the Cowboys game that looked
like that was a hell of a game uh but I
pretty much missed everything so uh I
think I got to go on the NFL Network and
try to watch some [__] but I'm
definitely going to be watching
um the Monday night game tonight and I
ain't going out I'm not doing [__] I'm
wiped out ACDC is playing tonight at
Dodger
Stadium and uh if I get a second wi I'm
going to go out there and I know what
you guys are thinking Bill how the [__]
can you not go at least go get some nose
bleed seats for that and I've just been
on the road for 15 [__] days drinking
smoking cigars and all of that [__] and
uh I'm completely [__] wiped out I've
seen them a bunch of times and I know
that this isn't their last [__]
tour you know what it is dude I [__]
up I didn't get tickets and I hate
myself right now cuz I'm not going and
it's going to crush me that they're
going to play and I'm going to miss and
I'm terrified that this is the last time
they're going to go and I know that I'm
going to regret that I'm not not going
to go tonight cuz I'm [__] wiped out
there that's the truth all right before
you jump all over me all right let's get
into some of the uh questions here for
this week uh Rugby World Cup you know
everybody keeps talking to me about this
in Japan winning I really feel like I
missed out on something man sounded
amazing B Bill uh dear billam B Bon how
the hell are you I'm good cuz he wrote
me too uh anyway uh I don't know if if
it's getting uh time
on Sports Center but the Rugby World Cup
is on in England at the moment the USA
are playing Scotland as I write this and
winning although probably not for long
uh just Jesus Christ what do they make
per
game to [__] knock their brains out
the you I'm talking about the USA team
um I'm a huge [__] fan of rugby and
uh I gotta tell you two sports that I
kind of make fun of that I'm actually
starting to get into I find myself
trying to fight it but if it comes on TV
I'm watching it soccer and
golf they're sucking me in uh just
wondering what you know Andor think
about the game I think it'd be right up
your rally big guys beating the hell out
of each other to move a ball to the
other end of the pitch There are rules
but that uh that's the guts of it I like
to hear your thoughts thank for doing
your job uh I benefit from it oh thank
you um any right to go [__] yourself um
I absolutely love watching rugby when
I'm in Europe or if in a country that
supports it I don't know what it is just
the announcers you can hear it in their
voice it means something you hear the
crowd it's just um there just something
about being over there I mean I I would
become the biggest [__] I'm going to
keep calling it soccer so American
listeners don't get confused with the
football thing um and please can
somebody for the love of God not ask me
again why American football is called
football you barely kick it with your
foot I've told you why a long time ago
we figured out that your football is
[__] excruciatingly boring and that
if you picked it up and added some
violence to it you know what I mean we
do everything on tent you
know I'm just [__] with you um no
when I'm over in in England like in
those Premier League games come on I
really get into it it's [__] great
how can you not if I'm in England it's
[__] cold out I'm in a pub I'm
drinking a beer and everybody's going
nuts and they're riveted watching the it
is impossible not to get sucked into it
and I have to tell you I am
fascinated by people who don't give a
[__] about sports fascinated and envious
of like God what do you do with all that
free
time I'll kill a whole [__]
Sunday right at the end of the [__]
day I'm sitting there like Eddie Murphy
in the clumps remember the outtake when
he had the ice cream pouring out of his
[__] He's when he had it coming out
of his bottom lift that's what the [__]
I look like by the end of the day and I
do it again the next Sunday if I'm not
flying at Toronto um I think rugby is
the [__] I think Australian Rules
Football is the [__] and I think soccer
football let me be respectful to the
rest of the world I think all of it the
[__] all of it's great man sports are
awesome I don't have a problem with any
of it and um if it's violent it's
[__] maniacs running around my only
real complaint because I really do think
soccer is a beautiful sport uh my
complaint is is the diving and I
actually at this Point prefer women's
soccer because they go down and they get
right back up you know they're [__]
men about
it all right friend [__] up dear Bill
my 26y old friend in my opinion is in
deep with a lady uh she's around 30 with
three kids oh Jesus and is recently
divorced good Lord
dude is he wearing like a weighted vest
just walking around around too to add
even more difficulty to his [__] day
uh they've only been together for a few
months but he's already got car seats
and [__] in his cars to tote these
heathens
around he's not what I would call a
ladies man so anytime he gets into a
relationship he falls in love quick and
you know what the world needs dopes too
you can't help him he said my concern is
that he's going to end up playing Daddy
to three kids that aren't his for the
rest of his life which in my opinion
sounds like a goddamn nightmare well
well those kids also need a father he's
doing something really admirable but if
he's doing it for the right [__]
reason it's admirable if he's just a
[__] dope with low self-esteem you
got to pull him out of this man you
know you got to walk up to those [__]
his [__] car and punch out the side
windows like the Terminator did to the
windshield and you throw those car seats
over the [__] guard
rail all right no I'm not saying to do
that all right anyway anyways um my
question is do I talk to the kid and let
him know that the that all of his
friends think he's going down the wrong
path here he's the kind of guy who
doesn't handle those talks very well so
I could see him going ballistic should I
let him know or should I let him crash
and burn one way or the other with this
I realize watching this train work for
the foreseeable future makes me a shitty
friend but as a but as Guys these
conversations suck dick uh listen dude
you know
he needs to grow up man if he can't
handle constructive criticism if you
just say look I'm just looking out for
you all right you're going to go from
being a single man with all the options
in the world to a a committed man with
three kids
instantly
um if this is what you want to I don't
know maybe that'll drive him further
into it I mean I and I also think that a
lot of reasons why like he doesn't do
well with those conversations is because
if he is somebody that just kind of gets
into something and gets trapped in
something and doesn't know how to
express himself that usually adds to a
lot of anger how do I know this because
I've been that guy um I
was very like uh withdrawn if anybody
said hello to me then I was friends with
them and I there was no asking what I
wanted what I needed what I was looking
for I didn't figure that out to very
late in life which is probably why I
didn't get married tell was 45 but at
least I wasn't dumb enough to get
uh to to uh get married to someone that
I I wasn't I always knew enough to be
like all right I got to get out of this
but I I I was not good at that at all
and I was a very angry guy um I don't
know I don't know what his deal is or
his psychological [__] backgrounds he
got an overbearing father I have no
[__] idea I'm not Dr Phil or Johnny
weissmiller here whoever the [__] I'm
supposed to use as a as a reference but
um you know know why does Johnny Weiss
Miller sound like a doctor he's the
actor who played Tarzan by the way um
anyways all right asking so I would just
say uh you know what dude dude [__] his
moodiness [__] baby just tell him
what you
think you know just sit down and just
say listen man as a friend I have to say
my peace on this thing all
right uh I just want to make sure you
you know what you're doing here cuz you
are taking on an unbelievable respons
responsibility and you are effectively
ending your youth immediately dealing
with this woman and these three [__]
kids that mean it's one thing to get
married have a kid you know fall in love
get married right and then have a kid
and you deal with that then you have
another kid you deal with that you're
just going
bam married kids three kids got to pick
them up to daycare or whatever it's like
yeah you don't need to do that and I
know there's a lot of people out there
who divorc with kids are probably
annoyed me right now but you know what I
don't give a [__] this isn't about you
this is about a man who's 26 years old
who he's got the world at his [__]
feet all right if this is what he wants
if it's what he wants you got to support
it but if he's being a [__] dope say
your peace so you don't have to feel bad
all right and then later when he talks
to you about it he's going to have to
say like you know what dude you all
right you'll be like you know what it's
all right it's all right you can crash
on my couch all right asking older girl
out hey Billy fat tits hey [__] you man
I'm in shape now I just wanted to say uh
you've encouraged me to lose 30 T 30 PBS
now since you began uh I did as well but
still have a few months to go dude
that's [__] great it's great man good
for you keep it going uh anyway anyway
to the question I'm 23 and the girl I'm
thinking about asking out is 34 I feel
like this may be one may be the one if
she's perhaps said yes because we click
so perfectly when we are together and
when does age become a
factor well she's 34 if she wants to
have kids I would think that age is
going to be a factor pretty soon uh or
should I just move on and try to find
someone around my age by the way a great
drummer to check out is Marco miniman uh
yeah I've definitely seen all his stuff
that guy's insane he goes I saw him a
while back at a Joe Satriani concert and
thought it was the greatest drumming
I've ever seen anyway keep up the
podcast and go [__] yourself yeah that's
the kind of guy he can like do a drum
solo to like you can give him an excerpt
of this paragraph in the way my voice
goes up and down he would voice it on
the drums he's one of those guys man
he's like he's like from another planet
um great call by the way ah you're 23
and she's 34 uh my gut says yeah don't
do
it don't do it 23 dude you're in the
prime of your [__] life I would get a
woman who's my [__] somebody 34 that
probably going to get married pretty
soon you're 23 you don't need that [__]
right get yourself a [__] Philly 23
years old dude you're drafted in the
first round and you're going to trade
down to the sixth round [__] that and I
know there's a lot of women that are
going to listen to me and say that
that's [__] but [__] you cuz women
do that to other women you guys give
each other advice like that on your
shows so what am I going to do because
of women's issues I'm going to give a
23y old guy bad advice dude [__] that
she's 11 [__] years older than you
she's going to be in a completely
different place women are way more
mature than guys are you're going to be
like a [__] kid all right and she's
going to be so [__]
Advanced as far as you
know having been in relationships dude
you're going to give up so much goddamn
territory my gut says don't [__] do
it don't [__] do that
dude don't do
that all right when you're 43 and you're
still P90x and she's going to be 54
going through menopause all right I'm
just saying this is harsh but you know
what I I wouldn't be a [__] uh I
wouldn't be honest if I wouldn't be if I
wasn't saying this all right now if you
but I'm not saying it it's wrong I'm
just saying all right my gut says when I
look at those numbers you know we don't
have a deal here this isn't a good
[__]
trade um but haven't said that good luck
to
you all right uh [__] jokes all right
what's up there sizzl nuts how are you
uh been listening to your podcast for
around four years now and you often make
a negative refence reference to [__]
jokes as a kid I always laughed at [__]
and fart jokes and now in my 30s I still
think they are funny uh why are they
frowned upon and do you have any good
ones is it just you or does the entire
industry not take the jokes as being
credible also you suck at the
internet last week you gave your mm
podcast email address when telling
people where to send their questions and
you said it's Bill atth capital M capalm
podcast.com email addresses and web
website addresses are not case sensitive
Chief thanks and go [__] yourself okay
you know it's [__] hilarious how
young people think that computers are
cool I I just don't understand what what
is so awesome about these fuing
than just you know what it is what you
give up in your free time and in money
and that there's a [__] camera and
God knows who's on the other end of it
and you have to like put a piece of tape
over it you know what I mean who knows
if your [__] laptop's open and you're
there [__] your woman and there's
some guy
watching you know jerking off somewhere
in another part of the country it's just
it's [__]
bizarre that's the that's one of the
funniest thing email addresses and
website add I'm not case sensitive Chief
did you flip your little [__] hair
after you typed that you [__] um all
right [__] jokes and fart jokes um
they're considered sophomoric bodily
fluid jokes and that type of thing I
don't completely write them off it's
just me just being self-deprecating just
joking around oh would you look at that
would you look at that I got a text
message I really needed to know that
while I'm doing a podcast you [__]
Apple [__] um put the mute button on at
least um anyways
uh so that's what they looked at I have
to be honest with you man I love a [__]
joke I love a fart joke if it's a good
one you know if somebody's just up there
so I'm [__] wiping my ass and pl you
know not saying anything then like I
think what happened was with the
oversaturation of comics during the 80s
comedy
boom
um you know there was there was material
that just everybody was doing there was
just easy laughs cuz I think maybe
that's what it is is if you do a [__]
joke it's got It's it's going to get a
laugh there's no way there just it's
practically impossible to do a [__] joke
and not get a laugh to get a to do a
fart joke and not get a laugh so um it's
considered like lwh hanging fruit having
said that I don't think there's anything
wrong with lwh hanging fruit like you
know I'm a big fan of [__] movies and
I love a movie that's trying to do
something different but if there's one
that's just you know one of those tough
guy movies and just right down the pike
nothing [__] new but it's done well
and their attitude is not that we're
doing something different here they're
just like we're just going to make one
of these movies I don't have a [__]
problem with it so
um you know if a comic's on stage doing
a [__] joke if it's funny I don't give a
[__] and if it's easy I don't give a
[__] if it's [__] funny it's funny so
uh but the reason why I use it as a
reference like [__] and Dick jokes is uh
it's just sort of um just a
self-deprecating thing that's all that's
all I'm trying to do all right gangs
Bill if if you were in a gang what would
your surrounding theme be I.E
motorcycles gangs involve riding would
you be in a comedy gang a New England
Sports Fan gang uh definitely more like
the latter it would definitely be more
like fantasy football nerd gang I'm I'm
I'm all right if you on one end of the
spectrum is absolute
uh total Rebels motorcycle gangs and
then the other side is fantasy
football I am somewhere between those
way more towards the fantasy football
thing I am uh I ain't no tough guy right
I'm not trying to go to jail I don't
need any of that [__] and you know what
I don't want to do anything you
know I don't be involved in
violence I just don't they don't explore
that part of me and I don't want it done
to
me um the [__] gang would I be
in I don't know I don't think I could be
in a gang that actually called it s a
gang unless it was making fun of
itself how about
Enthusiast you know God all of that is
too how about I go to a hobby one of
those Hobby Town places you know what
this whole question is giving me douche
chills congratulations to you douche
chills I always give credit to the OPI
and Anthony show uh the late great OPI
and Anthony show um when I [__] say
that cuz that's where I learned the term
and I never heard anybody else say it
was it Opie who came up with that I have
no idea I got to call an opian Jimmy oh
Jesus anyways that is the podcast here
for this week I hope you guys enjoyed it
uh thank you from the bottom of my heart
everybody that came out uh all the way
through Texas thank you everybody who
listened to uh me and Paul ver sing our
country hit America first um and then
everybody who came out in Toronto man
unbelievable shows up there and uh it
made me sad to to only be in all of
those cities only for one night because
uh you know I used to play the clubs
before I did the one nighters and it was
always fun there was all these there's
all these places food places all these
places that I like to go so um I
definitely got to get back to Toronto
during hockey season you know the hotel
where I stayed at we went
by ah Jesus what the is it the Molson
Center I can't [__] remember is that
where the Habs play I don't want to piss
off Maple Lea fans but I went by and I
was immediately remembered this story of
me and verie when we went to a game
there had the best time it was so cool
to bring ver there because he's not a
hockey guy and then you know anytime you
bring somebody to see hockey live they
freak the [__] out and to actually see
it in Canada an original six team with
that ridiculous [__] fan base all
right there's no way Canadian fans would
be showing up like Hab fans well you
know in the drought that the Toronto has
the fact that that's the hardest [__]
ticket to get [__] practically
impossible to get a maple leaf ticket
right um even when I compliment the
[__] May police I still have to trash
the Canadians I just have to do it it's
it's it's [__] habitual with me so
anyway so we'd gone to the game when we
came out it was just it was absolutely
[__] like you know minus 10° and
there was wind and we were trying to get
a cab and everybody was any cab that
became available people were jumping in
and I remember standing out with there
with verie and it was so [__] cold I
remember we just were just laughing at
first we were cursing our brains out and
then at one point we just it the wind
blew again and it was just so cold just
it was like I think we're just going to
[__] die out here um but I just I
have so many great [__] memories of
uh that Canadian tour that we did so um
as much fun as it was to do those two
shows it suck to only be there for one
night so I definitely got to get back
and um I did get to spend quite a lot of
time in Austin I had one day off that I
spent in Austin and then the next day uh
we ALS also we went to the the UT game
we had a great [__] time and
um what do we do Dallas and Houston
Houston I mean I went to Houston so
quick I didn't even get to go to
Southpaw guitars that's how fast uh we
went through town but uh hopefully the
next time through I'll uh spread it out
a little bit more and um once again
thank you to everybody came out to my
shows and uh I'll see all you guys in
the midwest um later on this
month
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
going into week number four uh before we
get started we have to shout out our
sponsor of course bmgm we love working
with B MGM guys uh with the B MGM sports
book all you have to do is use bonus
code bur 200 to get in on it it's a $10
minimum deposit in and then they will
give you $200 in wages regardless of the
outcome of your wager all you have to do
is go to the bmgm app download it put in
bonus code bur2 200 and put in as little
as $10 and you'll get up to $200 in
Wagers guys okay uh they're also still
doing the uh Survivor pool it's uh not
the 250k but you could sign up jump in
there and uh as long as your team
doesn't get eliminated you stay in it uh
every week the team just has to win uh
in order for you to keep going and of
course here at the anything better
podcast we want you guys to bet
responsibly and have a good time um so I
getting into
this I had a bounceback week I think
three in one but the Chargers the one
time Paulie takes the Chargers I mean no
no no no wait wait a second Paul Bersy
went 0 and four last week and then he
tells me dude if you think I'm not
sitting down like [__] ace rothin on
Monday going over this [__] you watch
yeah you watch me I'm gonna bounce back
Paul
verie almost one stupid [__] turnover
you would have gone four
and0 dude you're the only one that has
done that bill went 0 and four last year
and then the next week he comes back 4-0
I wanted to do it and the Chargers of
all people took me out of it the
Chargers who I lived on you gonna walk
away from them that's like me with the
Titans I can't lay off them oh my God
the Chargers are like the girl that
gives you a hand job under the bleachers
and then when you go up to her after and
think it's good she ignores you like
what
happened I thought we had a good thing
at homecoming dude I'll tell you last
week that was a crazy week it was all
right the Texans beating Jacksonville
the Colts winning yeah the Cardinals
beating the Cowboys I mean
I don't know I I I like I did not see a
lot of that coming I went one and three
old Billy got his freckled bun spank
last week Paul and it wasn't even close
either thank God the Pats were the ones
but Pats were my lock of the week I just
felt like Bill bellich going up against
that poor bastard playing uh quarterback
for the Jets I keep forgetting his
[__] name I just felt Wilson yeah
Zack Wilson I just felt like he was
gonna frustrate him but um
I'll tell you it's hard man watching
that Jets watching the coach getting
yelled at watching Wilson getting yelled
at those you know a lot of that stuff
the Jets fans are yelling about it
really has nothing to do with the Jets I
feel like it has more to do with their
personal life and they wanted to live
vicariously through some sort of success
which was going to be the Jets with
Aaron roders and now uh I don't know I
don't like seeing
that dud no I'm not even a Jet fan just
and Joe namoth come on man hold on here
Paul you're a popular guy people know
you're out west on the west coast they
want to have a meeting with you um
whatever I ended up going one and three
I've gone two and two two and two and
one and three so now I'm two games under
the [__]
waterline Paul verie came roaring back
no but you but you got me still you got
me still because we both were two- two
then I went 0 and four and you were two-
two and then now so now it's only I
think you got me by no but then you
picked up two games so I picked up two
games when you went 0 and four oh so it
might be even again but now now you
we're tied I think we're tied I'm two
Bill Bill I'm not coming for you you
know who I'm coming for I know you're
not you're coming for the book we're
friends here coming for the through uh
through three weeks bill bill is six and
six Paul no I'm
not I didn't I go one and three last
week no you I think you went two and two
I two and yeah you're six still in it
Paul and uh five and seven PA's five and
seven okay I'm five and seven you're six
and six all right so uh po still got
some six the number of the Beast hell
and fire was SW to be
released oh oh hip hop pully does not
know any Iron Maiden All
right well listen about Bruce Dickerson
Andrew it was always some crazy dream he
did that he said that twice on one
album is this for real or just some
crazy dream he says it on Hallowed be
thy name and number of the
Beast crazy dream all right sorry
um the surprise you first pick Paul
let's do it well here's the deal they're
not fooling me with this one okay
because I looked at this I mean I looked
at it there's no way what I'm seeing
here they're trying to reverse something
now I'm going to say this okay the Miami
Dolphins threw up a John Madden video
game number last week okay and they had
10 touchdowns in that game they they
they the defense was completely confused
now a team that does that is now the dog
the next week by two and a half to the
Buffalo Bills and I could be wrong but I
think that that's the book trying to
trick people and trying to move money
there is no way there is no way
okay that a team that does that comes in
and is a dog the next week without some
sort of manipulation on the book because
the book is g to get heavy-handed to him
because everybody's gonna take the
Dolphins so they want to scare people
away but guess what Bill they're not
scaring me my first pick is one of the
easiest picks I've ever had during this
I don't give a [__] that it's a division
game I don't give a [__] I've seen
enough I've seen an offense do anything
and I also seen the Buffalo Bills not
play as great as they could play I have
to see the dolphins after putting up
that point and knowing that they can get
back in a game if they're down a couple
touchdowns I'm taking the dolphins
getting two and a half points uh getting
two and a half I have to take them I
gotta see it all right Paul well I'm
gonna go the other way 75% of the
[__] money is on the Dolphins I know
you go out to Vegas Paul the lights are
on all day long and all night long the
doors are wide open they got the AC
cranking and they're not going out of
business you know how that is Paul
because of games like this it's a
division rivalry game they put up 70
points on a team that shouldn't even be
in the NFL if this was the Premier
League the ra the [__] Broncos
wouldn't have been let in this year
after last year all right that's a
Mickey Mouse defense it's a [__] up
organization they have a good head coach
they haven't figured it out yet the the
[__] Buffalo Bills are not the Denver
Broncos but I'm telling you right now
everybody in a buffalo wild Wings is
thinking what you're thinking and I
think you're all wrong all right Paul so
you tuck that chain back in no because
I'm [__] taking the bills laying two
and a half not only they gonna cover
Paul they're gonna win the game and
guess what we're gonna have a great
[__] uh back and forth between the
bills and the Dolphins this year the NFL
is an entertainment League Paul they're
not gonna let the Dolphins just run away
with this [__] and be foring out ain't
gonna happen all right okay I uh I like
the head your [__] pencil at me
either that's that's our first Head to
Head by the way Paul verie already
picked the Lions we just were too busy
to [__] do this on Thursday no I
didn't I did not I did not I texted you
you said the lions are gonna kill him
and they did I know but I didn't pick it
and if I would have said hey guys I want
this as my first pick but I did not do
that um you still said it was going to
happen I'm trying to I'm trying to give
you some [__] props here Paul I know
I should have had another win
oh and you're breaking my
balls all right so I got the Dolphins
and bills got the bills which is our
first head-to-head of the year which I
love well my cousins the head coach of
the bill so I can't go against
them you do look like that guy all right
with my second pick my second
pick uh a team that I said was gonna be
a good team this year a team that is
home with a doable game uh it's a
three-point spread and they lost I
believe last week uh I'm going to take
the Jacksonville Jaguars to bounce back
uh love that bounce back at home minus
three it's not a big line you're at home
and you're coming off of a loss that's
got Paulie pick written all over it I
loved it when I saw it Doug Peterson got
those guys ready to bounce back Trevor
Lawrence gonna have a big day I got the
Jags minus three all right Paul I don't
know which one I'm gonna take next but
I'm just going to throw this out there I
like the Steelers minus
three against was it the Texans are they
playing no they're playing the um
they're playing somebody who won and
thinks playing the Texans Texans yeah
they're playing the Texans I last week
was the Texans Super Bowl they're gonna
come back to earth I liked what I saw
with the Steelers I watched them this
weekend I think they're a lot
um they tightened up a lot of things
they looked a mess week one but I think
their coach has them playing football
they're only laying three the Texans
absolutely stink all right I don't know
what the problem is down there Paul they
got all that oil money you know it'd be
nice if they put it into their [__]
program but they're not so I'm taking
the Steelers laying three Paul I'm
taking two favorites so
far listen I love that pick on this
index card on this index card I have six
games I liked and guess what that's one
of them that's a w I have six I got six
that I like
um all right dude
look last week
actually last week or or a couple days
ago I got to sit on the couch with my
friend bill I got to sit on the couch
with my good buddy here and we watch the
Bengals on Monday Night Football oh by
the way by the way me and Bill actually
watched our Monday night special go off
the fingertips of AJ Brown unbelievable
we had them covering we had Jaylen herdz
throwing one and then [__] it was out
of his reach we watched it in split
screen and we go oh my God it was a
little high but you know a little we ALS
we also saw the Cincinnati Bengals
defensive line was actually better than
I thought and even though burrow
couldn't he only let it rip a couple
times I think gotta keep him in the
shotgun formation because he can't he
can't he can't do that three-step drop
there
um but I I like them minus two and a
half I like them to win again and get on
a roll I think they're going to start
rolling and I think his leg is a little
better so I'm gonna take Cincinnati Joe
Mixon Joe Mixon was playing great too
eating up the clock yep they got Jamar
chase you know they they got uh hi uh
yeah t y Higgins I'm gonna take the
Bengals minus two and a half they got a
win by three I think they go on a on a
little run now and uh I like that so
that's my third pick I like that too now
I don't know where to go here because I
like a lot of games here yeah
um I like a lot of [__] games here
who the Ravens playing I got them plus
three down
here they're playing the Browns yeah and
they're getting three points and the
Browns won last week ah the Browns are
coming back down they're coming back
down that quarterback goes out he gets a
[__] rubbing tug he's too little too
relax he maybe throws a pick I like the
Ravens I think uh both sides of the ball
I just think they're a better team and
they're getting three points I don't
give a [__] that they're going into
Cleveland I don't Paul I would say that
in downtown Cleveland right in front of
Hil Aries I'd say it to Nick's face as
much as I love him I like the Ravens
getting three points nice division
rivalry game uh the Ravens lost last
week I believe and I just feel like
they're going to bounce
back I think the rub and tug actually
helps him I think he's relaxed he stays
in the pocket he lets the blitz come he
sees it
slower um you know what I think that
that was the old him and Houston then he
got so much [__] for it I feel he feels
guilty about
it that's hilarious I mean everybody
knows after a rubb and tug the game
slows down now the G the game slows down
for the great ones but for us regular
people we need a rubb and tug to get
into their [__] mindset to run that
two-minute offense that's just what I
do uh I like the pick dude I think the
Browns are good man I think they're
really good this year all right no I'm
taking the Ravens dude oh you're taking
the Raven oh that's right you're taking
I like the Ravens dude come on Lamar
Jackson that [__] defense they got a
better head coach I'm telling you and
Lamar Jackson I'll put them up against
[__] uh what's his face at
quarterback that's a
push they're getting three points Paul
they're the [__] Browns they're going
to win two weeks in a row that's what
you're telling me the Browns Paul
they're home I think you know what
that's a coin toss that's a tough one it
is a coin toss but I'm getting three
points yeah listen gun to your head you
gotta like a Ravens defense getting
points um blue division
dude all right for my fourth and final
pick um
um you know the
Saints I think the Saints are a good
team this
year and I think that they were beating
the Packers hand handily and they let
they blew it with a actually they should
have won the game the kid missed the
third a 40 yard field goal to the right
at the end of the game now the Saints
came back home the Saints are coming
Marching In okay I like that the Saints
are coming marching in and they have to
have a bounceback win and uh what can I
say this is the Paulie homecoming Theory
a good team loses a heartbreaker on the
road and comes back home I like them to
cover it's three and a half I'm gonna
take is that kid coming back at running
back the [__] his name I love that
kidin yeah Alvin Camaro will be back and
uhe and it's a I don't love I'll be
honest I don't love the0 three I mean
the0 five I don't love that it's three
and a half if it was three I'd put my
[__] Lexus on it but I still have to
take it i'
still if it was I mean if it was pushing
his keys across the felt table I love it
if it was three I'd be online at City
bank right now I don't love the the the
three and a half but I'm gonna take the
game because I think they're gonna
bounce back at home I'm gonna take the
Saints up with the bounce back all right
Paul these are the last three games I
like I like Seattle getting one I like
the eagles laying eight and a half and I
like the Cowboys laying six and a half
against my
Patriots I like that because I just
think that [__] they have the next
Lawrence Taylor and I just feel he's
going to be all over M
Jones Ezekiel ellot though that's
they're saying that could be the you
know that could be uh it's a personal
game they might you know might might
might a 35 year old running back dude as
you
know Andrew you know you haven't said a
[__] word the entire podcast then you
come in with your hoodie up like Obi-Wan
Kenobi and now you got me questioning
myself I deliberately don't have Jake
the snake on the screen because I he
[__] he gets that look on his face
and he makes me think about things okay
Seahawks are playing who and who are the
Eagles playing Seahawks play the Giants
Monday Night play the Giants plus one
and then the Eagles uh are playing who
col Washington Washington yeah eight and
a half ah I don't like that division
rivalry game eight and a half's a lot
they see each other twice a year you
know what Paul I hate to say this I'm
going to take those [__] Seahawks
look I don't know who my Seahawks
getting one at home no at the giant
[__] I don't want I don't want to bet
against Paul vers Giants I just don't
it's at the Giants though by the way
it's at the Giants I
know you know what I hate to say this
but I'll do this because then I can
enjoy the game I'm gonna take the
Cowboys lay in six and a half againsts
my Pats no matter what happens well you
know what could happen is we lose the
[__] game and I lose the bet but I
just feel like
uh they got too many weapons on offense
and they have such a great [__]
defense I feel like they're gonna tire
out our tire out our defense and in the
second half Paul that's when it's going
to get a little lot of hand and they're
gonna cover first half I think I'm G to
be thinking I'm gonna I made the wrong
choice but I think in the end six and a
half is they're going to do it I'm going
to take the Cowboys hate to say it
against my
Patriots all right that's my brain not
my heart all right so I don't want to
hear it from all you [__] bastards
all right and that's it Paul guess what
those are my picks for the week the
sunglasses are on think too cool for
school all right so Bill Burr has bills
laying two and a half Ravens getting
three Steelers laying three and the
Cowboys plus six and a
half all right and I have I have the
Jaguars minus three I have the Miami
Dolphins plus two and a half I have
Cincinnati Bengals minus two and a half
and I have the New Orleans Saints minus
three and a half um now now bill it's
time for you to
sing wait a minute I'm gonna sing about
how I watched Paul verie golf the other
day man and he's usually Paulie back
nine oh no that wasn't the case Paul
after three [__] holes found his
stroke and a Jack Nicholas design Golf
Course was smashing it it was good
smashing it there was a a dog leg right
and Paul goes watch this he went a
little Derek Jeter little inside out hit
a flare to [__] right field went
around the corner that ball did
everything but make a [__] right hand
signal he played great it was fun man
Verina and I were uh I had him by three
three Strokes going into the last three
holes and I ended up holding on it was
we had a great time no you guys played
great I did I played like [__] and then
I felt myself caring I'm like what am I
doing and then I just started smoking
cigars I took a couple of holes off I
lost a few more balls and then my
daughter texted me saying she wanted me
to uh take her out for ice cream so I
bailed with like three holes left you
know family first Paul it was a self-
serving story all right and with that
Paul let the Monday night
special win some money for
you let the Monday night
special Jesus Christ Paul win some
[__] money for you this close so
close what are the what are the are
there two games
again why do they play the games at the
same time Paul that was the world two
weeks in okay just one you know what is
they know if as a husband if you watch
three back-to-back games on Sunday if
you were then to watch two back-to-back
on
Monday nobody's watching Thursday night
football because they're still [__]
buying flowers it's [__] unreal
man they watch those real housewives
marathons dude I'm still holding strong
Nia wants to go to the Super Bowl Mike
you're not going that's great guy trip
I'm gonna sit here for 18 regular season
weeks and you're not gonna be here
saying boo you're not
going no yeah you don't want a a wife
like Taylor Swift and the Travis Kelsey
sweet yelling when they don't know
what's going on yeah I know you don't
want that I don't want that at all all
right Paul what do we got who's playing
we got two games no one one it's one
game what's the line guys it's one
Seahawks getting
one oh Bill already picked that oh
playing the [__] Giants
o no no no I I actually I stayed away
from that game yeah
yeah the line is one and a half it's one
it's
one se's getting one Gino
Smith you oh [__] and it's in it's in
metti yeah it's in that place that the
New York Jets rent
right you a professional [__]
franchise and there's another football
team holding your
lease
um will you guys do that out in
California right with the Chargers and
the uh Rams what are you saying you guys
yeah what's this you guys guy I went out
to LA to get some of that Hollywood
money don't you ever [__] hit me with
you
guys ever do that again
Paul you know what I meant no Paul we're
gonna have to discuss that after this
podcast I meant where you guys
reside no you're right no they do say
yet to see the Chargers I gotta go to a
Chargers game all right let's going
that let's do uh all right Paul I'm just
gonna [__] you know you're Giant
so I I feel like I feel like Gino's
gonna throw
one all right I'll let you pick the line
what do you think Paul the Giants gonna
win this week we could actually skip
that and do the under over all right
let's do the under Rover what's the
under Rover Andrew uh let me let me
check see what it is now um saquon's out
or he's in he's in he's in 47 and a half
yeah 47 and a half 47 and a
half Gino Smith's been running a lot may
maybe
uh maybe do something like
that goo to rush I feel like that that
Giants always have a good defense so
he'll be contained I feel like he's
gonna throw
one and I don't think he's he's a
[__] smart quarterback he doesn't
want to [__] he knows what happens if
you run around you get hurt and that
guy's been to a bunch of teams he
finally has a start job I don't think
he's trying to run around and get hurt I
think he's trying to show that he's a
pocket pass that when needed he can run
for a first down but he prefer to Stand
Tall Darren John Wayne and throw a
touchdown I say Gino throws one Darren
Waller has had a touchdown on Monday
Night Football like the last six Monday
night games he's been in he's a big
Target maybe we should go with that stat
Darren Waller to catch one who's he play
for I'm not familiar with him he's he's
our tight
end all right okay I'll go with that and
then what about metf metf to get
one
um Paul doesn't like that sequan over
under you want to go over under how
however you want to [__] cut this pig
up I don't give a
[__] um I feel like it's going to be a
close game with the spread plus one
backing that up do you think they're
both gonna score 24 points
is I don't see it 47 and a half seems a
little high right yeah I like the under
and I think they're both really well
coached teams they're both really good
defensively I just don't yeah I don't I
don't see that many points I'd say the
under we got G throwing one we got your
big tight end I kind of like that Paul
okay so the under 47 and a half goo
Smith to one and Darren Waller to to get
Darren Waller to catch one yeah yeah now
what if he just catches a two-point
conversion that doesn't count right
doesn't count yeah well guess what a
two-point conversion you have to score
another touchdown that's what all you
kids don't understand because you just
think oh it's just two points it's a
[__]
touchdown Paul don't make me take my
sunglasses off explain
this all right that's the Monday night
special it's gonna win some money for
you Paul we are so [__] due we are
due man we're 10 months into this
pregnancy when is this baby coming out
dude the first year we hit like four or
five of them last year I don't I don't
know if we they changed the [__]
rules on us they went will chambering
those [__] but they they
lightened up last year is a wash um I I
actually this is one week that I like
all of the picks I like all four of
yours I like all four of mine I'm going
in optim Mystic we'll see what happens
um I I think I like what you did a
little better I am thrilled though that
I'm too I'm I'm [__] you know win
some you lose some I'm almost steady
Yeti over here dude you're you're you're
you're I'm in trim you're even money
you're you're right with the book
Paulie's got to climb himself out of a
hole still that 0 and four I'm still
it's and but you like that Paul Paul you
gotta flare for the dramatic you just
came out winning I mean well you can't
do anything you got you gotta come back
you gotta create like like an opponent
they didn't think I could do it I
[__] took my chain out turned around
mid October and I beat him
again I mean if you if you beat the book
three weeks three years in a row Paul
you gotta get the pinky ring I mean it's
just over if bmgm doesn't send me like
some jewelry or something you know gold
B I'm gonna buy you a fulllength mink
bath
rope and you're going to come on next
year shirtless with the CH it's going to
have a hood on it too well you know B
MGM said they would do something if I
did it three years in a row I want a
lion head gold emblem I want the bed MGM
lion gold around my neck and but there
has to be some sort of engraving on the
back where they
concede you called it B MGM you called
it all right I'm in Portland Main I'm
GNA go get a lobster roll with club soda
Kenny oh that sounds phenomenal all
right guys all right I ran into this
wonderful artist at the coffee
shop I don't know what the name of it is
but I I told him I'd wear his hat he
gave look at his hat man huh I'm out in
the [__] Woods here I got a little I
got a [__] a tree there you know my
this ey's going this way the other ey's
going the other way and my nose is like
what do you want from
me uh all right guys this has been week
four anything better NFL Edition you
guys have the picks you guys got the
Monday night special okay what the [__]
more do you need what else do you need
root for Gino to throw one which I hate
Darren Waller hey go make yourself a
plate get out of the kitchen go make
yourself a plate we gave you everything
get out of here there you go guys all
you got to do is um all you got it and
the under 47 and a half we don't have a
we don't have a winner for the game we
have the under um that's it go to the
bmgm app download it okay put in uh
bonus code bur bu
rr200 and put in uh a minimum of a $10
deposit and you will get $200 in Wagers
uh regardless of the outcome of your
first bet enjoy the Survivor pool how it
works is you pick a team not against the
spread and as long as that you get one
team a week as long as that team wins
you stay in it that is it for week four
you bet responsibly you bet responsibly
don't give your wife something to
[__] [__] about yeah yeah all
right hey every once in a while you go a
little big and if you lose your money
you're just [__] look at like you
think can't make that back yeah the [__]
do you think you married grab it right
by your [__] night coat right Paul
you get no no no no no get in a grill
like she missed an assignment no no he's
joking no he's joking uh he's gonna go
get a lobster hey Paul keep your headset
on I'm just [__] with you I know I
know uh all right guys that's this week
uh enjoy the games uh go Giant on Monday
Night Football Bill I'm rooting for your
Patriots against the Cowboys because
they're a division rival okay so uh I
hope that happens I don't know dude they
lost to the Cardinals last week I feel
like we're gonna we're gonna feel the
wrath a little
bit or Paul re is gonna get his [__]
revolutionary ass spanked I'm a little
nervous about that but I will be
watching well maybe Bill bich saw
weakness in the cowboys that he uh
exploits well he'll probably take away
CD lamb but then they got another number
one receiver on the other [__] side
and then they got Lawrence Taylor that
number 11 whatever the hell Peterson
whatever the hell is name m m pars
you're H Peter michah Parson I'm too
[__] old to know names all right I
know your number that's enough all right
hanging up on you I'm hanging up on you
I'm hungry all right later all right by
guys we'll see you next week